[Music]
do
so
[Music]
you
how i accidentally
became the biggest
chess streamer of all time me how is
that possible
oh please don't hurt me
oh my god
[Music]
don't worry
i'm down here guys uh
i saw you big man hey yay
[Music]
i am not a chess streamer i don't know
what i'm doing
i was just trying to draw a line but
accidentally dragged that
am i dead
we can kill him
no what wait what
i want a refund
can i stop my wife
and as much cash as you can carry you
can keep i don't care if you put in your
pockets and your hoodie and your pants
and your shoes you know i still need to
whip out my camera and
put on
a smile
to get my picture taken
paul champs competitor here
oh my god
hey guys welcome to thanks thanks for
the host
yeah moving the pawn out two squares hey
yo this move here is too rare he got the
two pawns out there as friends yeah
night came around yo we ready to end oh
my god the queen making moves already
yeah pull the queen out yo this dude is
heavy yeah and y'all know knights move
at the angle you're stepping up the mag
[Music]
oh it makes me so sad that that's the
last time we're going to be seeing that
particular pre-pre-show hype video
alexandra thanks for being with me an
upgrade today from little sister i don't
mean that no andrea is great nevermind
okay hi clip it and ship it chat you
heard it here first
i'm so excited to be here as well danny
the production quality has just been
fantastic this time around and i'm
already sad that the event is ending me
too and before we get to that we need to
remind everybody of what's on
deck for today we've got the
championship and consolation brackets
coming up for you in reverse order we
will start the day off with mr beast
versus rubios and then croakies versus
fundy i i have a cat mate outfit on the
line uh hoping that fundy wins
i don't know how your sister talked me
into doing that
honestly i have to give andrea credit
for that that was creative and we cannot
wait to see you what has to happen for
you to be wearing the cat made outfit
croakies just has to do what he's been
doing all event which is win chess
matches although fun fact for the stats
fundy has not lost or drawn yet he is
perfect on his way to the championship
while croakies on the other hand has
actually lost two games so who knows
what's gonna happen there but first up
of course
it's beast and rubius we uh we want to
remind the fans of how we got here and
what was a very exciting and long day uh
yesterday with your younger sister
andrea so on that note let's throw to
the coinbase recap and see what we had
on saturday
oh no
baby rage
magic rage
like when you
at the last second man
i'm gonna eat you in a little bit little
banana
i'm gonna restore my potassium i thought
you were talking to the producer for a
second
will you see queen h4
listen in
let's go
wow
oh my god
hell man
there it is there's the scottish man my
sister she comes in wearing my
sunglasses and has the audacity
to shake her booty at me a little i'm
getting tired
don't play queen eight seven
i take this
oh he's back to it oh my god he did it
right before my stream started i you
started your stream already and the
title is today we beat fundy and chess
yep
what happened
[Laughter]
how do i leave the interview how do i
leave
these guys we're friends fund me having
no mercy is it good if he plays check he
wants to draw
don't do it
oh my god oh my goodness
today
ruby is going to clean it up with rook
f1 that would be it better than the king
and queen and he finds it he says no
more king and queen checkmate stalemates
let's do this thing the old-fashioned
way damn nice
so did i have another option there maybe
i had like queen here
[Laughter]
god danny's so hot we don't we don't
need to do any turtle play of the game
because we got tie breaks we don't know
what the eternal place right now why are
you replying that but you can type why
no why are you playing that why no
fly okay i'm leaving all right hey
that's a good stream all right let's go
straight okay i'll be leaving all right
it's been fun you're gonna have the
trouble here camera guy
you're gonna get me oh my god
[Music]
all right i donated a thousand dollars
to his stream and intermission uh to
hopefully distract him a little bit he's
gonna be thinking so much about their
donation he's not gonna be focused on
this game of chess
triple big brain iq moves
mr penis
oh
my heart
i wonder i i don't know what anyone's
talking about right now
[Music]
you
absolute god he said you absolutely
there we go
who said you can't pay for winston chess
give the camera words of inspiration
okay or just paul champs invite me back
to your damn tournament i lost it was it
was a it was
i made it further than you i'm playing
more than i do
i know it was i i had a bad setup all
right hey hold on i want to see if i can
find a way to check
jackie we we weren't gonna we weren't
gonna mess with you you know honestly
you played terribly i mean it's okay
there were very few things you did
correctly today very few things
that's okay
as if we needed more reminders that we
don't want this event to come to an end
yesterday that was that was wild and
epic and i and i hope we get half as
many laughs today
that was incredible these highlights are
amazing it's been such a good show danny
seriously shout out to the team there's
so many people working hard to make
pogchamps awesome and sunday brings it
all to a close so shout out to the team
they're literally probably doing things
right now for our youtube channel or
social media just extracting highlights
from all these amazing creators so thank
you so much
and uh
on the last day this is also our last
chance to do what we can to raise money
for our charity uh rad rise above the
disorder is an amazing and amazing
charity doing awesome things for people
in need of mental health health care
affordability accessibility
encouragement at times someone to talk
to those are all the things they take
care of and we are two exiting donations
we see that numbers where we left it
yesterday we get over 30 000 from the
community that means more than 90 000
total with the 2x of chess.com so let's
uh let's get let's get higher than that
let's get over 100k total
do it yes i love it you know chess
supporting mental health super important
and i just appreciate everyone in the
community who's contributed here thank
you guys so much
for sure and uh let's also remind
everybody of our sponsor coinbase.com
slash chess is the place you need to go
to sign up get free bitcoin maybe you
can bet andrea maybe she'll be hanging
on the chat she's always looking to put
something extra and unnecessary on the
line and i lost my bitcoin to her
yesterday uh but would you go there get
free money you lost bitcoin 10 drea
danny you're losing everything i let you
commentate with her a few times now
you're gonna wear a cat mate suit you're
giving her money you're talking to
bananas you're losing your mind danny
he's devious she really is she's i mean
i don't even know what hap at the end of
the show i go what just happened all the
time with her anyway but i i i hope not
to wear a cat mate suit we'll see if if
fundy can can keep me keep me wearing
normal clothes for myself but we won't
find that out to the end of the day
right now we're going to take our last
break before the games kick off it's
championship sunday it's me it's
alexander botez don't go anywhere we
will be right back
[Music]
so
own streaming history while supporting
your favorite gamers and streamers by
buying their digital collectibles on
eternal collecting these sometimes
hilarious always epic gaming and irl
highlights directly benefits the
creators while providing you the fans
something unique and special to keep
sign up on eternal.gg build your own
collection and feel the thrill of
ripping digital packs and viewing
amazing moments in the marketplace
[Music]
oh we did it
oh man oh well gg
now we made it he finds it
and there he goes nice
please sleep that was
almost dancing
[Music]
i can't believe i just beat him oh my
god
none of you none of you thought i was
gonna keep this man none of you look
that that is right oh my gosh oh my god
did anyone just see what i just did
[Music]
everybody loves a happy jimmy the beast
donaldson but who will be the happiest
at the end of their matchup between
rubius and beast you're going to find
out a little bit but first shout out to
maypro we're at the break alexander
twelve hundred dollars to kick things
off and we've had donation after
donation ever since thank you community
yeah huge shout out mapreel has been
supporting so many charity events on
youtube we really appreciate it and just
an incredible community of chess players
that also like giving back
well
twist ending right now uh for the fans
tuning in the rubius mr beast match
actually took place earlier today both
of these guys are super busy and have a
ton of stuff going on first of all huge
appreciation to them for making sure it
happened so right now alexandra and i
are going to step aside and you're all
going to enjoy what was a live showdown
an epic one you are not going to want to
miss a single second
epic i'm honestly going to re-watch it
myself so
totally recommend we we are going to we
are going to sit here with all of you
enjoy as fans what happened between
rubius and mr p mr p find out who is pog
champs for consolation bracket champion
right now
we are getting set here for the
consolation bracket championship matchup
alexandra we look at the different roads
that both of these guys took to get here
i'm going to start off with a tough
question who do you think had the harder
road to get to the championship that
we're about to see
oh that is a good question i think maybe
rubius had the slightly more difficult
path here and he's also the more
experienced player in pogchamps what i'm
really excited to see today is how
seriously mr beast is taking ruby is
because we saw what he's able to do when
he goes hard on the prep like his game
against ludwig right
well you know i i know that jimmy had a
long night last night playing ludwig
poker for those who were following
anything going down on twitch so i don't
know how much prep jimmy threw down um
but you know i'm gonna agree with you
that i think i think that jimmy not only
maybe had the slightly easier road i
think he slightly surprised himself to
get here we see him stretching and
yawning and good thing for him uh he has
a chance to to maybe pull an upset on
championship sunday and uh and sneak a
consolation championship belt we know
that that's really
he doesn't care about much but he does
care about his belts and so i do like
that belt
so here we go you know jimmy jimmy's
here and motivated for the belt oh okay
and we have a scandinavian right off the
bat is this what mr beast usually plays
with the black side yeah he's been
playing it um really since since
pogchamps three when he first made his
his
is uh on pub on appearance on
camerachest.com debut now ruby has taken
a second to think does he not know that
that jimmy would play this he must this
is all jimmy has played really is black
okay exactly so
he should be someone oh let's hear it
here another free pod have a second one
oh wow
we'll give it
giving away pawns like he gives away
money except for yesterday he did take
50 credits everyone i played in
pogchamps never takes this other pawn
it's weird it's like they they think i
have a trap or something i don't i don't
get it
um
he must have been feeling generous um
yesterday he did give a thousand dollars
to his other opponent though tech tone
before taking all that money back or he
must have just known he was going to
beat the pants off ludwig and uh and get
all his money back when he threw tecton
a thousand dollars to distract him in
live fashion on saturday
that is true that is a nice way to
distract someone and also make them less
incentivized to beat you when they're
just trying to thank you and they feel
you know appreciative of what you've
done there we're tech tone but we did
him a favor he he said in his show he
didn't want me and andrea to pretend
that he played well so we told him we
said hey man you played like crap i mean
honestly that was horrible
wow danny that's so kind of you it was
great it was supporting new players was
good i'm telling you it made him love us
even more it made him turn into gremlins
danny you turned into a gremlin just
like andrea yeah she did she rubbed off
on me so all right we've got
a weird scandinavian like you said with
e4 and and d5 rubius also plays this as
black
but he didn't take the pawn like jimmy
said they all think he's going for some
trap and now we're in a
an awkward structure where white is
blocking the c pawn and black actually
has the better setup but let's tune into
rubius and see how he's thinking about
this
[Music]
what's your name
much more attentive to his opponent's
rest than he was back in february in
pog3
oh absolutely i mean he obviously really
likes chess because it's not his first
pog champs he's playing in and i think
his weakness is that he tilts really
badly if he's had a tough game but the
first game he always starts off strong
yeah
until the king and queen checkmate
portion of the game and then you know
yeah then it's anybody's game really all
bets are off um
well jimmy said yesterday after beating
techtone that uh he unlocked the cheat
code of chess which was he learned he
can take his time and actually think
about the positions it was like yeah no
man that that's a big that's a big brain
um so i'm saying that because he's
slowing down here and i think that's a
good thing i think if jimmy takes the
game seriously you know i've known that
from working with him and you know
he's better than he gives himself credit
for
and um if he slows down and takes his
time and doesn't try to do crazy things
i think he could pull the upset here
wow okay well i mean this is a big game
we're gonna see who wins the consolation
bracket and you know people always look
at the consolation bracket it's not the
championship bracket but it's basically
people who have had less experience been
playing for less so it really is a big
accomplishment here
no it really is and honestly i mean it's
like jimmy said it he wants to be the
best of the losers that's one way to say
it but i don't i don't think about it
that way because i think that in some
ways the consolation bracket is is more
exciting because you see players who
started out at a lower level but
progressed further during during the two
three week period right and and that's
always interesting to see and um
you know not to take anything away of
course from you know people like
croakies and fundy you know who will be
playing later on today um
they've also been grinding absolutely
and and this position is pretty solid
for both players so far there's not any
um overarching weaknesses the pawn
structure is a little bit funny um for
for rubius with his pawn on c2 that you
just highlighted and mr beast does have
a temporarily backwards pawn on c6 and
an isolated pawn on a6
but i i have a feeling the pawn
structure is not what's going to dictate
the game here you're i think you have a
good hunch on that i'm going to trust
your intuition um that that said it it
they are they are good enough players
that it may not dictate you know the
tactical moment or a blunder it does
dictate how you play the position up to
that though and i think it's a good
point to realize we highlighted that for
the viewers that often this is funny
because the knight wants to be behind
the pawn in any in any position where
the queen's pawn is the lead pawn in the
center because what that does is the
knight and pawn work together it also
opens up things like the queen coming
out so this is an awkward setup despite
the weaknesses that are these pawns
white doesn't have access to it so it's
it's a weird position now we see jimmy
moving a piece twice kind of riding the
wrong of bishop f5 decides you know what
i'm going to pin that knight instead
i actually don't hate that move i know
it neglects the principles but i don't
hate that move at all yeah i i kind of
like queen d3 here for rubius just
getting out of the pin holding the f5
square
h3 he can kick him back but he's still
gonna have to deal with the pin and i
know how annoying it is to just always
have this pin in the back of your mind
okay so he just takes the knife he's
going to uh double up mr b's pawn i
wonder which pawn mr beast is going to
take with here i was just going to ask
that right that's the the million dollar
question
and with mr beast we're not kidding
about that he he's not talking too much
i think he's i think he's taking this
super seriously but let's see maybe
he'll give us his thoughts
i like the thinking faces he has going
on here and position number nine very
well known to top grand masters such as
mohammed yarov and anish
luckily he doesn't he can just develop
and block his check with bishop e7 look
at that he does so
he goes right it must be the thinking
position it's powering him up
this is a big moment because that bishop
actually needs to come back to e6 uh i
don't
i don't want to take the knight because
then he's just going to bring his queen
around i don't really want his queen
there
so
he he could take the knight and get
counsel okay so just to keep
keep his queen pen
my worry is this move alexandra if if
this happens it's actually kind of hard
for white to get sorry for black to get
castled i don't know the ruby is going
to see that but this this would be a
really a really irritating thing for
beast to deal with
yeah i see rubius touching other pieces
and trying to think about where to go i
haven't seen him think about queenie too
yet but you're right that would put him
in a major advantage look at that right
as you said that he highlighted it yes
okay commentators curse but better
did he really
by the way like this is knights versus
bishops
advantages for both sides that are
different if i do believe if rubios
finds this that
this is going to be a really
composition for mr beast because
probably on a move like queenie too
the best thing would even be a like a
voluntary on pin of the bishop it's a
weird thing to do but
then you could start to write the wrong
and even play g6 and king g7 kind of
castling by hand at some point but it's
it's going to be hard to
find that although look at the time
ruby is getting down on the clock here
he really is but mr beast is only up a
minute and 20 so it's nothing too
drastic since now mr beast has actually
slowed down a little bit
but if he finds queenie too i think it's
worth
the uh
the time it's taking a toll on him
this just got interesting this just got
interesting
don't sack why is he not moving back
right away is he considering sagging he
has a smile it's dangerous oh no don't
do it
i bet he is thinking about it i bet he's
thinking about stacking and playing h5
hey
[Music]
come on jimmy tell us what you're
thinking
i think i just pull it back right yeah
yes
nice job the coaches are proud
i still like that he's taking his time i
mean yeah
um i i i'm good with just doing that
yeah very solid move and now once again
rubius has the opportunity to find
queenie two here
queenie two and then mr beast would have
to find rook a7 if he wants to castle oh
wow that is that's a really nice move
though um
that's a very awkward move but yeah if
you find rook a7 you keep an eye on this
pawn you defend the bishop and suddenly
the king can get out of the center um
i have a feeling rubios is going to find
queenie too but let's listen in i saw
him just highlighting b4
uh
now's not the time to make passive moves
yeah he did i guess he thinks
what are these camels oh it's the best
part of watching this stream these days
that in the and the kid eating the
burger i i mean
i like some very high energy
notifications
he i of all the streamers in the event
alexander all the streamers i've
actually watched on twitch he has a
massive variety of types of donations
and things that happen
yeah yeah i know those are pretty cool
hey castles for beast i mean jimmy
playing super well
this is wow
yeah they're both playing a very solid
game so far very positional knight e2
um he can reposition his knight to f4 g3
at some point it looks like he's
thinking about the c pawn
no blunders yet which we like to see yep
i mean not only no blunders just high
quality moves and
this isn't
a a very blunderful position and sorry
that sounded like a you know obvious
dania naradiski pun you know the
opposite of wonderful um
but but seriously like you can play a
lot of moves here that are just natural
you know
a lot of things with with your pieces
that just don't make blunders i mean
even c5 even f5 i think that
um
the worst thing about it is there's no
like really obvious plan to a player
maybe of jimmy's level so he might start
using his clock because it's hard to
know what to do here but
you know ideally i think you would just
start opening the position for the
bishops especially in kind of a
practical rapid game
right and jimmy is the one with a
stronger position here he has the bishop
pair um he has a semi-open b file that
he could use as you just showed to put
pressure on b2 and then if he does open
the position um
not only will he have his bishops free
but white's king is also a little bit
more exposed here yep that that being
said this is these are all very
strategic plans and as you mentioned
it's hard to find the right way to take
advantage of small strategic things yeah
and that's why he played a move like
bishop before because it's kind of the
more obvious thing to do right he
attacks the knight which is not a bad
thing that's obvious
rubius needs to find a move like knight
g3 here though because if he starts
backing up with the knight i think i
think jimmy will find a move like f5
but let's see what ruby okay knight f4
not no not as good as knight g3 because
knight g3 attacked the bishop
right
and it was a safer spot in general also
controlling f5 and h5
yep
all right because knight f4 isn't
actually doing anything here and bishop
d6 might come in with tempo
agreed bishop d6 is a great move and
then f5 and man can you smell the upset
i don't think rubius's chat wants to
hear it for an emo online chat they're
pretty active
all right
and he does bishop d6 on the board great
move by jimmy here
what's the jimmy's all smiles
look at that wholesome smile there's one
thing i've learned it's that i just
throw everything at the enemy's king
completely disregard my own king
and just pray
[Laughter]
nice it's been my it's been working out
for me the last few games in pog champs
and i'm not giving up on the strat now
you just fling pieces
and stuff just happens
he's doing well i mean f5 if that is
played next i'm
i'm nervous why do i love just
good flinging pieces at your opponent
and seeing what happens you know but
in this position in particular his
opponent already has a weak king so that
strategy actually works quite well and
his king is super safe
yep
see what he's thinking sorry what were
you gonna say danny why does he want to
go there
he really wants to bring that queen
around
f5 jimmy f5 is your move
like if i copy his hand position
it sends subliminal messages
yeah you're uh signaling him what to do
here
i mean not actually for those
conspiracies yeah i know you don't pick
favorites you don't pick favorites um
and again rubius is a little bit worse
here but he still played
relatively well i mean he's played very
well it's just that mr beast got a
slightly better opening position and
it's really hard to figure out what your
plan here should be as white
other than pushing the pawns on the
queen side where are they going to go
from there whereas black attacking the
king developing your pieces much more
straightforward
and i think
at this level just positions that are
easy to play are usually the winners
especially because then you can stay up
on the clock that being said mr beast is
the one who's getting down on time now
so who knows anything could happen when
you're under three minutes yeah
i love that rubius laughs every time the
camels pop up on his stream
it must be some special type of donation
[Music]
was a weird move by jimmy
he wasn't talking much so i don't know
what his thought was but that could hurt
because
that was a weird move
he locked in his own rook and put his
queen on the file where now he cannot
move his bishop anymore yeah yeah and
also
it prevents you from ever playing g6
right
yep you uh you don't want that to happen
no you don't no you don't fork town
working
i think he may have been panicking
because of the time situation and
sometimes you know you just get a move
so that you're not oh stuck using half
of your time on one move
okay rook v8 not bad but still the only
way to really fix okay and a great
response from ruby is not just that he
played it that he played it quickly
because the clock is right back on jimmy
the only way to fix this alexandra is to
move the queen again which is what
worries me because it's really hard to
do that i think once you've
psychologically committed but i don't
know what other plan he has besides
bring the queen back
get it off of this file
yep
i love that we could just make an album
of all of his thinking faces the
close-up ones the mystery evil ones
that's a new calendar coming your way
why do people spam chats with emotes
like what is the psychological feeling
they get the the dopamine that is wrong
you feel like you're participating in
something and not just actively watching
i mean it feels like an experience
conversation i get but spamming i'm
watching rubio's chat and and how wild
it is and i'm like
what do you get from yelling in the
audience of a concert
okay okay fair
um
that's a that's a really good comparison
actually by the way jimmy did fix the
problem with queen d7 and now maybe
he'll find f5
oh man and and king g2
both players are putting themselves in
pins quite a lot here now f5 is really
strong he's starting to pry open his
king side i'm so impressed with the way
he's working right now and no this is
incredible
i think we might have at least one game
upset jimmy's smiling it's just
nerve-wracking nerve-wracking it is i'm
nervous
they're both so focused this is this is
good to see and okay so let's try to
figure out what could rubius even go for
here he doesn't want to take that's
probably the worst option
um g5 yeah
yeah because the position is just so
open g5 at least closes it up
um but not for long because he can still
try to to grab that pawn with something
like f6 in the future maybe not right
away here but at least it holds the
position together for a little bit or
you could leave it on g4 but it's
attacked twice and i don't see how to
defend it so maybe g5 is the only option
here
yeah and and the thing on g5 is you
could actually play f4 trapping the
knight and suddenly you're right just to
make a random move your idea of f6 is
actually really nice and g6 because the
knight runs out of squares you take away
the four key mode with f6
and then g6 one little tactic
yeah i know that looks brutal maybe
after f4 white could try to you know
attack the bomb with a queen and keep
fighting but
beast is certainly better there's ideas
like this in the end if the queen isn't
guarding f3 that's true that's true um
i mean okay rubius is under a minute
let's tune in what's he got for us
he likes your g5 oh i like it i like it
just don't flag rubius
he's he's excited though he's clapping
he's feeling the kill rubius is under a
minute so cute that's so cute
i love seeing pure excitement
when people play chess
yeah and i know we all keep saying that
he looks adorable and cute when he's
excited but he just does i'm sorry i
know he's a you know 24 year old you
know superstar millionaire youtuber but
like he just gets so excited when he
wins chess games it's amazing yeah he
was clapping we didn't have the seat up
at the time and he was clapping at the
position and that's just just awesome
chat spam people wine
here he goes this is your moment jimmy
you got to own it one opportunity don't
let it slip mom spaghetti
uh you know lyrics a little bit out of
place danny but you did your best
i did my makai fifer ain't no movie
i'm
on the streets
oh my god i really thought andrea would
have beaten out the dad jokes out of you
but i guess you need more time with her
she tried so hard she tried to oh i bet
the dad out of me
we had some real struggles with her you
know
just well we just were not seeing i'm a
35 year old old dad he's a 19 and she's
a 19 year old gremlin i mean it's not a
good combo
yeah
okay 17 seconds for rubius a minute 25
for beast this is it the consolation
bracket championship the finals as they
say yup
and the thing is it's harder to defend
than to attack so if mr beast finds one
good move here that just forces rubius
to think that's all he needs wait why is
rubius's clock running didn't he just
oh we've had some moves i'm sorry let's
go back and uh to check out rubius's
view and all of our friends we made a
move some i was on analysis there my
fault okay okay
okay so
g5 was played
rookie ate by jimmy
and this is where we stand you can see
ruby's position is live
oh my god this position looks so
terrifying for rubius i think mr beast's
got it as long as he doesn't blunder he
just needs to keep using the clock
and rubius is doing his best to defend i
really give it to him here he's just in
such a tough position
oh my god it's going to be over
you just gave it to the queen i mean it
doesn't matter though he was going to
give me
he didn't he didn't have choices yeah
this is not his fault he has no time in
the heart
and an impossible to defend position
honestly because mr beast played the
attacker so well
yes let's make sure we see
[Music]
that one
foreign
he's taking phones but h2 is checking
i'm just clearing them all out we're not
risking it we're not risking anything
here
he's just taking the phone just go for
the mate come on you know you want to i
just queen g4 i
just don't or anything really
uh
any checkers
yeah that's true
that's fine he can get another queen if
he wants
and then it's not really possible
i'm playing it safe i could probably
check made him buy it
you could definitely check it out you
don't see beast playing it safe often
you know it just it makes the gambles
pushes the pawns you know
um
it's it's sure there you go queen d1
come on no
we're gonna we're slow playing them boys
oh my god i'm just so nervous he's gonna
find a way to stalemate
[Music]
okay please any check is made make sure
this isn't a freaking stalemate
yep
check and it won't be stalemate that's
all you need to do just check
that yes
if i move this pawn it's a stalemate
right
no which pawn
i don't know i don't like how many
pieces i have here i'm pulling my bishop
back too much to think about it
i
i just stand late it's terrible
um
he's been traumatized danny he looks
like a man who's been traumatized by
stillmates there's just like
no i don't think i am
any check is made i don't know i don't
know what to do
can i just want to
i want to get rid of his pawn his pawn
makes it too is it bad to sack my queen
here
i just
i don't like having this many pieces
just take it please just take my queen
trying to not steal me
now i'm actually wearing my stomach
[Applause]
anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
the one time i don't think about a move
was that dude if if he strategically
sent that message right
then so i wouldn't process what i was
about to do
i
i don't want to play can i just can i
just forfeit can i just forfeit this
entire thing i don't want to play i
don't like chess chess isn't fun it's
like
no
he just
any move any check was made
for every move
like
every check
unbelievable
if you guys are watching and you're
afraid of stalemate if you or someone
you love has been traumatized by
stalemate it is not too late to get help
we have classes available on chess.com
just check it might be made and it won't
be stalemate if the king is in check
this psa brought to you by chess.com
oh danny that was really painful i i i i
uh oh i feel bad i feel bad seeing those
i'm happy for rubius because this
celebration is awesome but oh
all right we're going to take a very
quick break when we come back it's game
two what in the world is going to happen
next nobody can predict it don't go
anywhere we will return
[Music]
so
huh
[Music]
pogchamps 4 is presented by coinbase
whether you're looking to make your
first crypto purchase or you're an
experienced trader coinbase has you
covered earn crypto by learning about
crypto with coinbase earn power up your
trading with coinbase's advanced
features get exclusive rewards when you
spend with coinbase card and much more
learn more at coinbase.com
chess
all i can say
is i hope we have something else happen
that's dramatic enough for this not to
be the eternal play of the game that's
all i can say and
it was like a puzzle danny it was
actually brilliancy he had a position
they were all checkmates he's a content
creator he wanted the storyline he found
the one way to stalemate and that took
some level of genius okay he set it up
so the audience could enjoy it more
um five heads in the chat let's show her
support here because he played such a
good game until he did
he play great and
i don't know whether we'll air it or not
but we see jimmy with his phone just so
everyone knows we literally just had a
phone call and he had he actually is
he's still so new to the game people
forget that alexander like yeah he's
very new to the game he really only
started playing at the start of the year
after the queen's gambit and he he
didn't know that
if you check it's never possible for it
to be a stalemate as long as you check
it's not a stalemate and so he was so
worried about stalemate that he wasn't
giving a check but now that he knows
that
gave him a pep talk we'll see what he
can do in game two here
okay well he's got the white side of the
pieces
we got the queen's gambit oh my
god take the free
on this is his new favorite line he
likes this blackboard stuff
oh no
the crazy stuff you know what whatever
makes him excited
uh that if that seems worth it ruby so
we're gonna try this again why does no
one ever take my f3 pawn
take it please the man just wants to
give away this pond he likes gambits
boys only want one thing and it's
disgusting they never
um look at the counter gambit from
rubius
now they're really just flinging pieces
at each other
what's the correct move here
let's let's look at rubius's stream
alexander you see the chat
right there
yeah
beast is trying to chat with rubius like
you did with techdome and he's not
accepting the chat request rubius is
just ignoring the chat request i don't
even know if he sees it
yeah rubio seems too focused on the game
that counter gamba from rubius is
actually a main line against the black
market by the way he played e5 that's
that's actually a good move i don't
think he knows the theory but maybe with
anna being the coach i maybe i have no
idea yeah anna anna's an incredible
coach but maybe he also has good
instincts um just trying to develop his
pieces potentially take the queen on d1
if the pawn gets taken
all right and beast decides to block up
the position here
um i'm not gonna try to speak spanish
right now and offend a lot of people
are you sure danny you just have such a
great accent your spanish is so good you
know you want to do it danny come on
make a dad joke in spanish do it danny
do it i know that el rubius means the
rubius
you are welcome world
thank you i don't know what we did to
deserve you you're such a blessing danny
truly
i also know that el nino is spanish for
the nino
oh my god you're really blowing my mind
here
thank you thank you thank you chris
farley and thank you the academy i'll be
here all week don't forget to tip your
waitress okay bishop five
now beast just develop bro just develop
i i'm not even rooting for jimmy i just
don't like heartbreak and when you when
you stalemate it just
uh
i mean i think yeah rubius has a
actually a really nice position here it
seems like you're just rooting for it
for the accurate moves knight c3 makes a
ton of sense developing putting pressure
on e4
rubius has played this opening
incredibly so far especially since it's
one he's not used to ooh mr beast you
don't want to do that now queen h4 for
rubius he's got to get that check in
and then he has completely destroyed
beast's king's side you don't want to be
so aggressive like g4 that's usually
what happens when players are upset what
happened previously and they're trying
to lash out on their current game
do you think rubius is going to see it
danny yeah let's see what he's saying i
think oh my god he's arrowing it there
you go rubius with the bait
[Music]
look at the chat everybody you can see
from mr b saying i'm not stalemating
this time
i like rubius's music
he why does he look shocked he's the one
checking that's what i would expect
beast to look like
yeah
i don't even know he's got 40 000 live
viewers right now he seems super chill
there's that clap okay and now i got my
own what he can do is little version
he didn't see it coming
wait
wait is mr b saying he didn't see it
coming as if this was a good
why
i don't know
but then you can pin it
all right i gotta put some thought in
hold on um
nice good time to sink here
all three or four
or four
all right this is
probably jimmy's best move here
ruby should take with the bishop
in the night um oh yeah not that
although taking with the queen allows
rook g1 for jimmy like a natural
move
slowly work his way out
there's all
there's a method to the madness here and
if you guys just give me enough time i
can show you why my king needed to
exactly
be pinned right here
and uh all right let's see the method to
the madness
imperative for winning this game
g1
but i guess king f2 and bishop e3 to
block bishop c5 check i mean he has
chances to defend it
um it's probably his best shot here yeah
it's just
the heart
doesn't kick the queen e4 is coming
yep
what a night and day of two games last
game what did i bring my other knight in
a grand master
yep
kind of it happens chess be like that
sometimes
okay so
he's considering moving his other knight
but e4 is still coming in in that
situation
rokuji one at least he has some kind of
attack when you're in oh okay he played
92.
now let's see if ruby is cz4 that is a a
key for him here
yeah let's tune in
look at that
all over it
[Music]
do
jimmy still needs to find rookie one
though
even with e4
losing a piece but it's not over if he
starts to get his pieces in the game
all right well let's see if he sees it
here rook g1
last attempt you have to you have to
deal with aggression with more
aggression sometimes
like completely fine i said yesterday
sometimes you also just have to give up
on your dreams
did she say that yeah
wow she was really born to be a
motivational speaker
you and i need to have a conversation
offline about you know what to tell
thirty six thousand people
give up on your dreams
andrea botes 2021
okay i haven't seen mr beast this quiet
in a while he knows he's in trouble yeah
he does and it's kind of exciting when
you know you're in trouble then you
start playing your best because just
pulling off any kind of upset is so
exciting
uh oh all right
that is gonna allow bishop c5
the bishop c5 check is played
yeah
i don't know what i
i don't know what's going on
in queens i'm just gonna hope that i can
just overrun him with all my pieces if i
if he goes jam
oh bishop c5 is so scary here
all right but
i really should be moving quicker i
think my only hope at this point is to
make him run out of time because he
wasn't the best but time managed my last
game
well it's hard to make your opponent run
off
run out of time when they have about six
minutes it is a fair strat when they're
both low on time if you're just trying
to make your opponent move quickly
i think we see rubius is all over this i
mean he's
the tale of two games
he's about to play bishop c5 check from
our preview and wow there he is
if he does it we could have we could
have a checkpoint in this game before
boot 15 i think
he did it yep
back to e1
e1 would be the best
because then you keep the question
another stalemate
what
all jimmy's got to do is get to the king
and queen end game
rubius has struggled with that
[Music]
okay
if jimmy plays king e1
i'm saying there's still a chance oh
yeah you know
a lloyd christmas mary swansonite dance
but a chance
yeah
um
this is scary now if you get
queen
h4
that's a free queen so i guess actually
that doesn't work and i've been
suggesting it my bad
i mean every time i have a chance to do
it there's i know look i'm just there's
that vote
hey that's something you could have
potentially fallen for gotten excited um
okay so what are his best options here
what should mr beast be trying to do
he just he has to take the pawn because
if he doesn't f2 is checkmate so
i mean okay i guess you could play
bishop b5 check as the only other move
all right taking the punt great awesome
yep
yeah i mean if he has a
couple more moves
um
[Music]
it's not going to be
honestly
rubious would have to just not see the
best way forward and mr beast would have
to be just
slowly untangling his pieces
he looks like he's praying for it
but remember i mean
last game
last game any check on the board was
checkmate for jimmy
any checkup okay
i got a game plan
i just okay he doesn't
i can check check his king yeah i just
need him to not
do anything crazy right here yeah i just
need him to just
just
you know
don't
don't develop any of those pieces you
know keep those nights back there don't
don't be well actually i
ah
okay queenie two trade off the queens
here yeah just don't get checkmated
even bishop b2 is okay the only no no is
king are you gonna trade queens i don't
want to trade queens i had a plan
no you do you might want to trade queens
here and not get mated
is he going for that pawn
no uh-oh
i guess we just trade queens
okay we're happy with this good stuff
keeps the game going
it's probably darn i was gonna put his
king check and then put his my
white script oh anyways
this is really nice it alleviates so
much of the pressure that he was dealing
with the kingside attack here i think
you're saying the pressure inside of me
you're right my heart attack my already
taken your heart attack how are you
feeling daddy coach much better here
thank you very much for asking
yeah i'm glad to hear it
okay there we go we have another mr
beast clap at least he's high in he's in
high spirits which is important
yeah it's exciting to feel like you're
getting out of things yep
playing quickly
okay they're both under four minutes now
speeding it up
oh
no no no no i forgot that was the thing
i'm just gonna quit
i suck
i don't know no no no
oh
come on it happens i honestly thought i
i just completely forgot there's a night
there i had a plan to with my queen and
then i forgot once i lost my queen i
didn't do the said plan
but
let's not forget it's never over we saw
what happened
never over just try to trap his king
he could get his king to safety maybe
he'll psych himself out and think i have
some way of like
beating him here and won't really be
painful
maybe i'm back in it
i also need to move really quick
because uh
like i've said him many times
okay he didn't psych himself out
i mean i'm just going to do it oh
gosh there goes a rook
but again if oh he didn't take it we
remember moving fast oh god oh my gone i
was gonna say i think if i move fast so
i think i have something
and then uh completely backfired i've
archaeological games i've accepted it
he took andrea's advice he gave up on
his dreams
he took andrea's advice worst thing
anyone ever did you know yeah truly
um
i i do like him playing fast to maybe
trick rubius into doing a blunder
himself
i mean we've seen so many players in
pogchamps be up multiple pieces and
still not close it off so he shouldn't
give up here
yep and ruby's under three minutes on
the clock you know after the last game i
believe anything can happen anything can
happen anything can happen i believe
hey c4 he's pushing the ball i honestly
i don't know it was gonna be a song and
then it wasn't it was just my i thought
you were going r kelly and that you
believed you could fly oh
knight c2 oh god
the forks no more stop the brutality i
don't want to see it anymore oh rubius
is getting
getting excited hey actually maybe he
stalemates me you know
that's the spirit
there's always a chance
still made for the lols
stalemate for the lols
there's mr beast type into rubius live
chat ruby is looks so angry right now
did he see the message or is this his
focus face i think this just would not
want to mess with him when he looks so
angry
[Music]
they'll make for the lulz
oh if rubio sees
and so oh my god look at him he's
already playing
well he just has to give up all his
calls and go for a stalemate
statement
i'm totally
capable of doing
that yes
[Music]
the music would really would really fit
a stellar yeah the music with a
stalemate would just
it would all be scripted
yeah we're in a clown show here
[Music]
good
a plan
[Music]
get rid of your pawns jimmy there you go
there you go give yourself a chance
[Music]
oh man
i've never stooped so low i'm openly
rooting
for a car crash wow daddy a train wreck
hey you're you're rooting for the
content aren't you
okay
one more pawn to give away
gonna come down to the wire looks like
he's gonna do the ladder check
everyone loves the ladder because it's
the one you can't mess up
exactly
what were you saying danny about the one
you can't mess up can you can you say
that one more time please for the people
in the back
okay
okay if he moves the night it's still
made
if he moves the night it's gonna be
stalemate don't do it
or the pawn oh he's he's memeing he's
doing it for the meme
[Music]
hey i feel like he did that on purpose
i
[Applause]
yeah i think he did it for the meme
that's
kind of the kind of whole kind of
anti-competitive but you know that's a
man with some honor
oh my god
thank you
that's what matters
that's what matters wow okay
he he he set it up all right
i guess it's a tie break
i don't know that he did that on purpose
sure danny keep telling that to yourself
danny
i mean his reaction was pretty like
i mean unless we're talking paid actor
you know they accused rayne wilson of
throwing some games in the last pog
champs
but i talked to rayne i don't think he
did i don't know i think
i think he he laughed when it happened
and he didn't do the latter which he
know he can do i think this was his way
of being a bro after what happened in
the first game which at the end of the
day you want people to enjoy chess and
give it one more game one more tie break
for the people the two content creator
masterminds rubius and mr beast
good luck finding an eternal moment
after this match everyone we're going to
take a very quick break and when we come
back the consolation finals here in
pogchamps 4 is going to tie breaks
just don't yell scripted
[Music]
no
we are back in the wildest consolation
finals championship we've ever had maybe
we'll ever have again between rubius and
jimmy the beast donaldson
the game's about to begin it's three
minutes plus two second blitz it's a
tiebreaker
alexandra i got i got nothing here i got
nothing
don't let your memes be dreams mr beast
got the stalemate there this is the
final game between the two of them
uh let's see what happens mr beast going
for another scandinavian his c6 trick
always works if white doesn't take this
is a great line for him as you're just
giving him advice before the match this
is okay
this is funny why am i okay okay
give me a collab
he probably looked back at the analysis
and had like a deadly way to like
screw me
it's developed
you're right
recording stopped
okay so this is gonna be much faster
place they only have three minutes and
two seconds it's hard to switch from 15
minutes to three minutes and get used to
it
yep
okay e5 is a good move developing but
rubius did probably look at it and this
is a better thing to do just take the
pawn because from ruby's perspective if
he develops and trades he should be
doing great
yeah
um
mr beast's pawn structure on the queen
side looks a little bit suspicious right
now uh not to mention he is down a pawn
but he has the bishop pair and he likes
attacking so let's see what happens his
scandinavian game was definitely the
better game between the two even though
uh playing black should be
disadvantageous
um
he was he was in a great position as we
saw and the stalemate heard around the
world is what happened
but you know what rubius was such a
gentleman he uh he returned the favor
he returned the favor
just two lads hanging out having a good
time they just wanted a little more more
play together
to see who's the better chess player
well now i think they're both going to
be
all in maybe we'll get into another
organic stalemate who knows because with
20 blitz less time on the clock
right
[Music]
yo
he's getting excited let's see if beast
defends that pawn
and he does he plays queen d6 defending
the pawn
um and the cool thing here is that
normal moves work for both sides there
you go let's let's see some castles
castles or or bishop g4 will probably be
what he plays
true that's also solid
they're both pretty similar on the clock
as well yep
give me a little bit down
oh
on time
yeah he goes for bishop g no the way you
said he was down and he had a very sad
face for a second
okay h3 kicking it out bishop h5 i don't
want to see g4 from rubius yeah we've
seen hopefully he learned the last game
yeah
the problem is it's clearly one of those
moves that he often does and he didn't
do it this time okay he's fixing his
habits bishop g5 that's really nice to
see
yeah it's a good move
black should still just get castle just
to avoid avoid any of the the nastiness
that could happen with a king
in the open board
but i don't know jimmy's gonna do that
yeah castled
or h6
uh
all right e4 is a bold move
he hasn't castled yet and white could
just take the pawn
for free
with either um he can even yeah with
either piece he can even take the knight
on f6 and then capture with the knight
if he wants to keep the queen on the
board so this was not a great move nope
but it is a move that's going to make
rubius think and sometimes that's worth
it in blitz but look at rubius he goes
quickly that's a good idea right he's
his model's always been safety third he
goes right into it
he just takes it
okay queens are off let's see if jimmy
takes up three to double the pawns nope
he just gets castle he's playing quickly
they're both very aware that this is
this is gonna come down to
some scrambled eggs in the end
yep
okay and uh
g4
back up okay well
neither one is talking very much no
they're not all right c3
pushing the bishop back the pawn on e4
is under attack as ruby is going to try
to defend it
okay aggression defends as well
russian good decision
yeah
e4 is hanging
um
any kind of natural move now very good
rubius is playing playing some quality
chess here
he really is
that's a good move opens up the king and
maybe prepares to put a rook on d8
that's that's a good move from beast
time is time is really almost even now
and uh we've seen our first blunder our
first big blunder of the day bishop f4
just retreat the bishop keep the bishop
uh-oh
and now if knight takes g5 and mr b sees
bishop takes f2
oh
that would be brutal
we need to see a move like king g2 here
ah
you played it oh my god
oh my god what will jimmy find i don't
know if he's gonna see the whole board
no he doesn't he misses it all right he
didn't he he's not seeing the the f2
again they're both under a minute on the
clock so we we got to keep that in
perspective here and he's probably
tunneling on the fact that rubius has
that pass pawn on e6 that's very
terrifying okay h6 is a is a good
accidental move so to speak because he's
not he's not spotting this opportunity
i'm not talking much about too much to
think about
but this is a good move
where does the 94
has to do 94. no options right here and
then the e6 pawn hangs so the tunnel
vision kind of worked out if that
happens
uh oh rubius is uh getting under 30
seconds on the clock and mr beast is
thinking on his time that's exactly what
you want to be doing during bullet
oh
oh you got to break a few plates uh to
make some scrambled eggs is that what
you're saying with the oh is that it no
that's really not what i was saying but
i love your creative interviews bishop
team
okay king g2 is nice he's gonna try
maybe he can try oh god this is brutal
i don't even know what's the trickiest
thing to try i would rook d8 maybe ah
they're all lost oh my gosh the problem
is you're not even threatening to take
so unless jimmy blunders with the eight
that's the only blunder if he takes the
rook
any other move in black is still winning
if we have another stalemate what are we
going to do
we're banning stalemates danny i don't
want to see any more stalemates on this
freaking website okay i just told jimmy
in a call i need to be the innovators
use your social media influence and get
it to go viral and i'll give her the
stalemate
uh-oh the rook's gonna hang nope jimmy's
gonna check him
oh man
there's just there's just
rooks
everywhere i'm so worried about another
stalemate
oh no ruby is my flag
ruby has to just make any moves play
quickly just push the pawns three
seconds
oh he did it with 42 seconds he moved
move again
oh
no
oh my gosh
oh
well now i feel bad because i feel like
he intentionally still made it the
second game to make up for my stalemate
so
that doesn't doesn't feel as good as i'd
want it to feel
but
gg
yeah i don't
gigi gigi rubios
no matter what this is fun this is some
of the most fun i've ever had
oh
well that's what we like to hear and
they were both
you know good sports towards each other
i i think for the first time in our
eternal play of the game i'm gonna
nominate two positions because the
moments were roughly the same
we had a stalemate to the likes of which
we've never seen here in game one
where annie check for about 20 moves
wins and mr beast
creates one of the most amazing things
we've ever seen on in a live chess game
a stalemate that we didn't think was
possible
and then in game two
rubius
returns the favor obviously we're going
to ask an interview it seems to be the
case because i think he knows the rook
lift but he found a way
to put jimmy's king in the middle of the
board
those double stalemates forced a
tiebreaker and ultimately forced us to
what we just saw which is mr beast he's
taken home the belt he is the
consolation bracket finals champion here
in pogchamps 4. type eternal in the chat
right now make sure that you uh you
nominate the moments that you believe
deserve
eternalization look at that i added a
word eternalization we're just making
stuff up three lucky winners will get a
free pack because guess what you can't
buy them anymore alexandra at last night
at about 9 00 p.m
uh pacific time all of the packs sold
out they are gone
well this is awesome not to mention that
a hundred percent of the sales from
these packs are going directly to rise
above the disorder so it's really a fun
way to gamify giving to charity and
capturing and commemorating some of the
best moments of the tournament so i
really like i got two because i bought
one and they're giving me one for free
because they're sweethearts at eternal
so maybe i'll turn that around
and make some money right that's how
this whole thing works right um
so anyway we're going to see how people
collect pokemon cards but you can
collect the moments online there you go
we're going to take a very quick break
again type eternal in the chat if you
agree with those moments getting added
the packs have sold out we will be right
back with interviews of our two
consolation bracket players before the
championship bracket gets underway
[Music]
do
gentlemen if we're all here for the
content and that's what matters you guys
gave us some of the best content we've
ever had right there rubius
what was that stalemate what was the
stalemate there
hey he said he wanted a stalemate for
the rules and i did it so yeah
but i was joking
no i was totally aware the the king your
king could move anywhere
so yeah but
it's because yeah you did it too in the
first one right it was because they yeah
yeah it was fun i i i've never never
never played a
uh a three-minute match on the
tournament on pakistan so it was really
fun but stressing very see we both
purposely threw games so we could have a
tiebreaker
yeah of course of course
well uh maybe
maybe we'll get you guys both the belt
then since you for your efforts you gave
us extra tie breaks extra chests it was
awesome i i gotta say guys
like make it like a code champ
i kind of like that yeah because
technically i still made it and then you
know and he kind of threw but he beat me
there so technically it really is like
50 50. i don't want the title
i've got two of these and i'm sure grip6
doesn't mind making a third one after
fundy uh and and croakies later today so
you know what you guys you guys think
it'd be funnier
honestly
if you cut it in half
and send me home
it could be like friendship bracelets i
used to have one that says bff and you
guys can wear it together
that makes me feel better well guys
don't worry you deserve it you play
really cool really okay well if he sends
it to me i'm cutting it in half and
sending you the other half so either
he's doing it or i'm doing it if you
want that so yeah that's cool
we're gonna send you both one so you
don't need to but hey i know you guys
both got into chess around the same time
you both made your debut in pogchamps
three now you've played this and and
let's be honest right we know chess is
hard and sometimes it's unforgiving and
stalemate
bleep and sucks i get it right but but
talk a little bit if you would i guess
i'll ask you rubius first despite the
hard moments how fun has it been you
guys went from pogchamps 3 to now
playing in the consolation final and and
how much have you enjoyed kind of the
chess journey over the last eight months
uh well it's more fun now because i
think i'm
i'm at the same level as mr beast and
jake yesterday and stuff like that so
yeah i i feel like i'm playing with
people at my same level and that's
that's awesome because
it's it seems kind of fair and
i've been
yeah i've been playing a lot with anna
with
juan ho and
they've teach me a lot of stuff and
so yeah it's it's thanks to them and
thanks to
to
to the
what was it called the puzzle puzzle
rush and stuff like that that yeah
i've become a little bit better than
last year
jimmy same to you man i know i know what
there were times when you were like oh
man why am i freaking playing chess
right now but you also had some so many
great moments but how has this been for
you
i i think i'm same thing as him like
when i did last pogchamps i had just got
into it so i just got destroyed i think
i won like one game the whole time and
so now that i've you know i had six
months just to play occasionally and
stuff like that it's it's exponentially
more fun when you can actually like you
know be slightly on par with people so
yeah it was a lot more fun and i'm glad
i stuck with it wait what being good at
the game makes you enjoy it more who
would have known right right yeah just
getting dumpstered every game i mean it
was like brutal because there's also
like 500 games when you play pogchamps
so if you suck you gotta suck again and
again and again
oh well this was a really incredible arc
and you know mr beast uh you played
poker with ludwig yesterday after the
chest are you going to challenge rubius
to a poker match as well well not only
did i play ludwig i stole 25.00
i watched you guys last night and as
soon as ludwig said double or nothing
and you accept it i was so happy i'm
like ruby's gonna take i don't know b's
gonna take all his money i'm so happy
yeah i mean rubio's if you play poker
i'm always down yeah okay okay
real cool um rubius you didn't wear a
suit but you did give us an amazing
match i forgive you for the suit because
that sweater looks great on you the suit
yeah the suit smelled a little bit so i
couldn't
because in
so yeah it smells a little bit
well thank you for sharing uh i think we
all wanted to know that very well
i'm just giving you the reason i i
promise you i love the honesty
i will
give you the suit and i didn't give you
a suit so that's that's why
awesome well um i got nothing else i
really appreciate you guys uh people uh
you know this is this is um been a been
a tough schedule as you guys said hard
to fit into everyone's busy lives you
guys are doing amazing work for your
fans so thank you so much for playing
and um we really do appreciate it and
who knows what the future holds with
more pog champs and maybe a shorter
event maybe you're right jimmy maybe
this is just a little too long at times
but we we really appreciate you guys and
this has been so much fun
all right next one i want to win it all
right
there you go we went from being the
worst to being like average to now we
jump up and we win that's that's the
climb you got the trajectory going the
story line it's perfect yeah it's my arc
all right thanks for having me everybody
thanks guys bye thank you guys
oh man
oh man sorry i was letting them letting
them take uh take a a moment to step
away
we uh we got to remind everybody again
we are here for another reason in
addition to the chess rise above the
disorder doing everything they can
helping thousands and thousands of
people get the access they need get the
support they need both financially and
otherwise to seek help for their mental
mental health and uh
it's it's an amazing thing and we're
super pumped to be 2xing the donations
so that means we are i'm hoping to get
over 100k in total we're right around 30
from the community which means we're at
60 from chess.com about 90k total we've
got to get there by the end of the day
everybody really hope
we can do it and type in rad for more
info or just hit the donate buttons now
and make that make that happen captain
we will be right back with the
championship final so don't go anywhere
[Music]
i just like i thought there was multiple
times like i could check me in but i was
just always worried like oh no i would
somehow still me
trying to not steal me
now i'm actually wearing my stomach
i was just gonna like get queens and
then just ladder because i've never i
know i just won't pick up a ladder and
then in my quest to get two queens i
just threw
yeah you were i honestly it was one of
those things where you were almost you
were just you were being too ahead of
yourself because any check was made and
you just uh you got unlucky trying try
trying for the ladder but man hey dude
you played great dude you played better
than him you i'll play them start to
finish
seriously can we can i start a petition
the band stalemates dude i'm with you if
you help this go viral on social media i
will i
all right man hey dude thank you for
doing this i'm sorry that didn't work
out but don't you don't give up you're
now white man i'm rage i'm rage moving
rage flank all right let's do it okay
bye
[Music]
did you see my stalemate i did not i i
was up like 20 points and then i still
made it
is that game one yeah game one if if i
win this next one i still win right
that's right yeah but and if he wins
this next one he wins that's right i'm
an idiot have i ever told you that i'm
just an idiot
you didn't tell me but i figured it out
yeah
i'm depressed
that was painful
dude so tell me is this right so you
can't stalemate if you always put the
piece in check right that's what that's
right
someone just told me that and now my
entire life has changed
well i'm just gonna do that when i i'm
up like 20 pieces
it's not about strat
just every every move has to be a check
just check until you somehow find a mate
yeah
i want to die all right i got to give
oh he's he's memeing he's doing it for
the meme
dan
what's up dog i feel like he knows what
i'm going to do dude that first game i i
know you guys think i'm just being nice
i'm not kidding you played amazing if
you played just like you did in that
first game with the d5 c6 thing i mean
you had a great position
literally in the end you just you know
any any check and that game's yours so i
would be confident to play your
scandinavian again okay so i can just
play quickly
should i feel good if i win though after
he had to throw a game for me no dude
you should so great you you literally
have had the match in game one so just
win this game and then we'll deal with
that later okay i feel bad all right bye
[Music]
look at the subs again
today mr pog
pog eye
means handsome and tag
along
good luck
oh
pogi
okay
i i believe we can do this chat
we got this i believe
i have to believe
[Music]
i hope we're on chess.com again this
time i'm not looking it up but i hope
we're on chess.com twitch prime
twitch prime
wait
first prime
half a year first party
smile it should work
i am
let's go
now that's now that's where it's at i
can do the bid again
i can do the dumb bit
do we do the bit hold on
let's go hello let's go
hello hello
now that's not that's where it's at it's
just chess.com again
yeah please do the dumb bit we do the
bit yeah you should do the bit
do the bit
do the bit do the dumb bit
do it hello
hi
hello hello hi
i'm so close to being in the basement
hello hello hi i already said hi we
already spoke before
again it is chess.com yeah we already
know it's chess.com we already know it's
just that come on we've already
established that we are already doing it
yeah i know we're already doing it
that's what i'm telling you that's what
i'm telling you i just said that i'm
already doing it i know you're already
doing it because i just said i said hi i
just said that i'm the one who just said
that
yeah we already know it's chess.com i
know it's just.com because i told you
it's just that comes i told you in the
past yeah i know we're already doing it
oh my god you're so stubborn you are so
stubborn why do you never listen to me
you're already doing it because i know
you're doing it because i told you
why don't you listen to me
you're not listening to me
i know it's just.com because i told you
oh my god you're so annoying
why
wow
okay
oh zero mistakes zero blunders exactly
what we're after let's go man you played
97 accuracy do you realize how
messed up that is
oh that's not gonna do it oh my gosh
ggg
oh my god
what a game
what a game that's actually that that's
actually insane
[Music]
we're back we're live this time
alexandra
wow wait are you sure this isn't
pre-recorded prove it daddy
say something unexpected
we finish each other's
sandwiches
yeah yeah yeah
we did it
that really had no proof on whether or
not this is live but uh good to see you
guys in the chat i see people spamming
for croak to bring it home
what about fundy where are his
supporters
i think they want me in a cat made
outfit but we don't want that we want
fundy anyway i gotta give a quick shout
out one
that mr beast rubius match was amazing
and shout out to both those guys for
those of you who don't know it was a lot
of behind the scenes
just drama for the last less than 24
hours because they're very busy uh mr
beast is already on location shooting
somewhere else after a live poker match
versus love wigs so he squeezed it in
rubius has a huge fortnite tournament so
thank you to both of them hope you guys
enjoyed an epic tiebreaker
thank you to ryan sconner miguel mendoza
mooseboat j wall so many big donors came
in while we were not live um and really
appreciate where we're already at
alexandra i think if we get more than 33
000 then we're then we're over 100k so
let's do it let's get more than 33 000
from the community
we're so close you guys another 2
300 we're almost getting there it's
being
given towards mental health and making
sure that everybody can treat whatever
issues they have so very very good cause
with red we just got a big donor from
someone who was that
botezz live hey wait
that's that wasn't me
is that recording
unless it was andrea
okay did somebody donate on my behalf
thank you
i really appreciate it that's the nicest
thing you can do you're so nice
alexandra thank you to the other
alexandra in the warp time zone who's
also donating from the ninth dimension
um
whoever that was while we have
everyone's attention let me also remind
you that we are hiring at just.com we
pay in chess boards and chess pieces i
hear a rumor that some of us at this
company get cold hard cash as well so uh
tune in and go to chess.com jobs browse
around maybe there's an opportunity for
you or maybe you have a friend or
someone in in one of the fields that we
need who you think might be interested
in and joining the greatest chess
company in the world and we are hiring
more than 30 honestly like i keep saying
that graphic is is out of date uh we we
we're hiring so much and we we need help
and we're super excited about um where
the chess world in general and where
chess.com is going and we hope that
you'll consider joining us uh when we
when we uh
come back no no we're starting right now
no there's no break we're getting into
it shout out to john john with the other
yeah let's go
yeah fundy's eating a banana by the way
bananas are delicious fun fact
oh my gosh bundy sent me a message the
other day
do you have any name ideas for my
soon-to-be service dog
service cat
are your dog's service cat
this is gonna be awesome
exist
i think do service service cats exist
i don't think they exist
they would all just be dicks i don't
think they would help you at all i feel
like they would only help you if they
get food
yeah here we go all right it's time
boom terrified all right here we go
hello i'd be stopped time for gaming
so he starts with that i've never seen
him take
but i don't know his opening either so
it's kind of terrifying
okay so we've gone to this position
[Music]
now what the [__] do we do we go here
we go here thank you for the gifted subs
to fundy so take take take
take that's all fine i think we go here
first
cool
i don't like his knight
being able to go here
i'm not keen on that
i can put my knight here so i think i
think i'll start with this if his knight
goes here we go here
we need fundy five head today not fundy
blunty
right because if fundy wins you don't
have to wear the cat made suit right yep
oh my god look at croakies he already
knows the theory queen b3 this guy i
mean
they are playing for the championship
match this is where the real five heads
who have been studying their chess not
just during the tournament but even
before come out uh what percentage would
you give croakies versus fundy rating
wise and just general expectations
honestly right now i think i give
croakies a huge nut the fact that he
knew queen b3 means he's he's looked at
this line he knew fundy was going to go
for it because queen b3 is the best move
and it's the grand master
refutation if you will to um
to this to this idea of bishop five
because typically when there's an idea
to hit your queen side light square
pawns this is a very risky move
specifically because of queen b3 and
after queen c7 white can actually just
win this pawn on d5 if croakies if
croakies goes for it which we're already
looking in on his on his uh stream and i
think he's about to do it
oh my god i'm so nervous
i can't
i can't calculate like a turkey straight
holy crap
sorry spray part lines are the only
thing i can say
so that's obviously good but then
[Music]
yeah i mean
the screen can come in but i don't think
it's done anything too
insane
honestly the fact that he wasn't sure
about taking the pawn alexandra makes me
even more impressed that he played queen
v3 it means he kind of just figured out
he didn't even know the line
yeah so not only is he prepared with his
openings ahead of time but he's also
finding the right ones on the board here
and there i felt like he was taking
quite a bit of time but i see fundy also
is um they're actually playing at a very
good pace
like experienced players would yep um
oh my god that is a big water bottle
there's a very large um vessel that he
drinks from
i've been yes
i've been commentating on that thank you
i finally have a co-commentator who also
acknowledges these odd things on camera
i said it what is that huge thing that
he's drinking from it's huge well i'd
love it if one of the commentators are
just gaslighting you pretending they
didn't see it at all letting you start
to question your own sanity
what water bottle are you talking about
danny that's robert's job when he's here
um
yeah so so fundy was a little slow he
couldn't decide whether to take with the
pawn or the knight
um
and now that he
oh
okay
yeah he did make the right call but he
is gonna be down
upon now but at least fundy is getting
these tempe in development yeah i was
going to say e6 is exactly what you
should do there
um and so you're like you said you're
going to get a little bit of
compensation based on the lost time
white gets still better for white and
the computer would say so too but not
not quite a whole pawn if you will given
the initiative that black is is going to
develop
i do like this attack
[Music]
bundy does not seem concerned at all
about the pawn he just drops he seems
happy with it but you know what that
might be the mentality you need
yeah well i mean the initiative is real
and often easier to play with right in a
practical game you're not on camera so
you just took a huge jug of something
over there i'm gonna i'm gonna make fun
of you when it comes back yeah that's a
large he'll just lose this so he's gonna
have to move it
i'm just staying hydrated danny
oh but then we don't just check because
there's that
you can put us in trouble i like that
he's thinking on his opponent's time
yeah exactly then we can
get the night out
that way
[Music]
so that sort of helps us
yeah when we can when we can get our
knight here we can put a bishop here
because it's protected by the knight
[Music]
this isn't jack you can put it all over
it you're right thinking on his
opponent's time
i told cutie in a lesson we had right
before her matchup with croakies
unfortunately
rookies didn't go for the the line that
we were looking at but i said you know a
lot of people look at top players and
how quickly they play but they don't
always appreciate the work that went in
before it was their turn was their very
hard workers on their opponent's clock
and that's what allows them to impress
and
really you know it's hard as a content
creator but the key to high-level chess
is often the work you do on your
opponent's time not your own
so that's good stuff yeah no that is a
very key thing because otherwise you
could just be focused on your own time
maybe relaxing a little bit and then
tunneling and missing what your opponent
is going to do so trying to think of all
the different possibilities and
reminding yourself of what they're
attacking is a very useful skill to have
yep
oh man if you're just tuning in where
have you been hit the follow button if
you're coming in from twitch for the
first time this is the uh
the most watched chess event in history
and maybe until the world championship
comes up in november that's the podcamp
series itself and this is the
championship this is for all the marbles
winner gets 20 grand
um and it's
i don't know it's i think it's a lot of
money
but it's also just for a lot of fun so
thanks for being here absolutely
absolutely so pro-key pushes e3 here
he is trying to get his light squared
bishop out so that he can castle bishop
b4 is something that we saw fundy
looking at earlier to try to get a check
on the board but at least he has bishop
d2
i'm struggling right now
[Music]
let's hope it's dmca free
shout out to myself for that 75 dono
there you go
and chat with the cat jams
okay good to see everybody here with
their energy for the final match you
know what we might not be in an arena
but we feel
you guys from wherever you are so thank
you so much
oh he didn't play it though he can still
do it next bishop d3 was a blunder from
croakies
if
if uh if fundy just goes with the
logical thing which is to capture and
then play knight to b4 these are both
very
clear attacking moves
he played a6
but when this queen moves he's going to
have a second opportunity to capture
and then fork on b4 because it's a fork
of the queen and the c2 square
boom
and fundy has been doing his tactics his
um chess.com puzzle rating is 2400 so he
loves doing tactics of course it's a lot
harder when you're actually playing a
game because no one tells you hey you
have a tactic right now try to find it
but this is the moment let's see if he's
going to play bishop takes d3 knight
here nice not looking at it well here we
should be three and knight before wins
material
[Music]
if we keep putting pressure on his queen
he is much lower in time though
i like this move i'm actually not
against that
ocean yes
music
bam
different one is getting up on time and
that's something we've seen from
trophies in this [__] action she's
been down on the clock
yeah uh under five minutes
but
he should be very grateful that he
didn't have to end up getting his rook
and king forked on c2 i don't think he
saw it so he probably doesn't know he
should be happy the thing is if they
just end up trading bishops croaky is
going to be up upon down a little bit on
time but it's going to be you know
anybody's game
yeah
it's only i mean the structure is
so equal right this is the only pawn
that's extra and even though it is an
extra pawn very hard thing to prove um
it takes a lot of technique and practice
and in fact
if if fundy played a move like rook c8
and castles would play even queen c2
this is the kind of position where
the extra pawn may not be as valuable as
the open file and the play that you get
because of it so
um okay fundy has played b5 but
still anyone's game and and i like
fundy's advantage on the clock
yeah fundies advantage on the clock two
minutes there
um
not necessarily
crazy yet
especially since the position isn't
sharp but if he couples it with rook c8
um
then even though he's down the pawn i
would uh start to like his chances
gotta take grandmaster chess weebs
hanging on the chest.com chat we see you
i am spitting facts he's proud of my c
file on the second rank you're welcome
i like that they both got the hats going
on today
oh
is he gonna put his rook there he's
gonna trade two rooks for a queen that
doesn't seem like a good trade okay i
think he's changing his mind yeah that
would not be good for croakies i'm not
sure if funny would go for it but oh
i think he's gonna do it
oh
[Music]
okay
now it's time for fundy to take the rook
yeah i don't think he sees it let's
check in on him
really really bad
okay oh he does see that that's a bad
idea nice
you know i think we have to move
i think oh he's not even considering
taking the rook
that's interesting
you know it's funny because of the
mistake we can not to do it but either
night back and go here
here here maybe but from a practical
view alexander
either way we gotta get her not on the
left side the less experienced you are
the easier it is to play with the queen
right robert and i talk about that a lot
and we even talk about it even at the
highest levels in the scc the speed
chess championship
we say
in in faster time controls even for the
world's best like you often see blunders
happen uh um in in in the scramble
because it's easier to play with the
queen but um
objectively of course it was it was
better for fundy to do this if you're
watching at home and you're like what's
the actual chess
the chess meta the chess meta is this is
probably an easily winning position for
black like seriously the two rooks are
dominant and the night coming in but
it's very hard to commit to that
especially at this level so
yeah to just think about giving your
queen like that
and
i i don't know if he's keeping the fact
that he's down a pawn in mind but ooh
now the c5 square is looking so juicy
for croakies it's spicy you know
very spicy that's a spicy yeah
yeah exactly i don't know not great with
accents but i was just going with what
you're it's a spice you know okay but
i'm not okay no now i'm going in the
board but and i okay hold on here we go
we're back if knight c5 there is knight
b4 though
oh look at croakies with the prophylaxis
up in the house stopping i like it
giving no counter play
still though 347 versus 516. i don't
know what's going to happen here
yeah
agreed
i like croakies a3 is such a big brain
move i mean that's that's high-level
chess
and the truth is the c5 square is
probably better used initially by the
rook with the idea of doubling and
if if he leads the way with the rook
i'll be even more impressed because that
shows that
the super pretty knight is actually a
little bit kind of purposeless there
there's nowhere else to go but the rook
allows you to really improve on your
position by doubling so
yeah
um
rook c5 or knight c5 honestly i'll be
happy with either because that means he
sees this key square
bundy
is looking at a5 for some reason with
time advantage we're done one pawn
but if we can win by him being stressed
out by time that's very good so he's
aware of the of the pawn
hit that move croaky sees it not exactly
c5 but he sees the idea and fundy goes
right back at him with the death man
just a couple of and what did you say
last game couple of good lads playing
some good chess huh
exactly if he takes i take go back here
now now he's got the open file of tempo
now the knight's come back but still
yeah knight c5
then he has to play something like queen
a7 to defend that a6 pawn she does have
it protected and that's not good
all right fundy you gotta move your
queen and protect the pawn
d6 or a7
i'll have to go here to protect that
nice
he's all over it
playing some quality chess moves these
two guys are should we go here
[Music]
they're playing something that's yellow
like i'm going to go get you a prank
like let's just kill i can just hang in
this lounge
yeah just chess and pianos
[Music]
let's keep the audio going and bring
them back it looks like they're both
popping their head into the same music
yeah
oh they were
it looks like they're
listening because
okay
how do we make progress from here though
without question
okay so he's considering blocking up the
position
oh his knight would be better placed on
c5
he's you can tell he's nervous and he's
acknowledged it listen okay now stuck
come on
i don't know how to make progress
without obviously like i can push these
pawns but
when
no these are very good questions
[Music]
oh i don't know if i like h4 all the way
that's a little bit aggressive
f3 also weakens the e3 pawn but at least
he doesn't have to worry about back rank
but now he gave the opportunity for
funding to get the open file
wow
i yeah they're both playing super bowl
f3 king of two but you're right it does
oh look at that fundy taking advantage
of the pin
trying to bait him into taking that
knight and gobbling up his rook on c1
right
you also have to watch out for tactics
so even though what he did objectively
computer still likes white from a
practical point of view looking at the
clock i'm now worried about all kinds of
opportunities for something to go wrong
over here on the king side
yeah no this this makes me really
nervous um
not to mention the fact that he has time
and he's losing over and over and over
five seconds
buddy is just a little faster he really
is so now we just go here look at that
look how fast he's responding
wow
um you can push this pawn
that would be
oh man he made the right decision to
back up the knight there
reason being if we had if they push this
bond he had this eye to leave and he can
take the pawn
the fact that he saw that's so fast
we'll just we'll just rotate a little
bit who is this man and where is bundy
live
it's obnoxious bundy has just been on
fire i've been so impressed with this
play throughout the tournament and even
before
he has such a natural knack for chess
this whole idea of croakies oh my now
he's played kg3 he's walking himself
into blunderful territory
it's a blunderful life
oh my god someone write that down that
was an amazing pun take that donut
that's the second time you've said it
danny you can't keep copyrighting these
puns no belonging
it's a wonderful world i had said oh
you're right you're right what a
difference how can we forget merry
christmas
god bless us everyone what wonderful
life
all right chad you're just always
blessed fundy should be a little bit
careful there's no background checks yet
at least then i can hop back to f8
chat chad is very happy with your joke
chat can we get some collapse for the
dad jokes
thank you i'll clap for myself um all
right there you go danny hart there you
go now there's a back rank check on c8
though bundy's got to watch out
[Music]
i love that croakies
here comes the jug of the big thing he
got the big thing out
he's chugging it
gonna power him up
power it up
[Music]
need that energy
wonder what he's drinking when he needs
energy
yeah we don't know what's in that water
bottle
might have some liquid elo in there
liquid elo oh my god that is a great
brand
yeah isn't that a great brand liquid elo
liquid elo
excuse me
that is a new chess.com product liquid
eagle i'm not even kidding i'm glad you
like it liquid elo
love that
you're writing a lot of things down this
stream danny your jokes who's gonna have
all your dad jokes and then just look
when you love it i've been saying i've
been writing things down since high
school guess how that worked out this is
actually amazing for croakie that he
traded off queens because now he's up a
pawn he has to be careful because the
black king is more active but i'd say
this is a good progression for him he's
now better if he you know doesn't let
fundy's king
start tickling the pawn on d4 and b2
agreed
if if this knight comes around though we
have this outside chance that the b pawn
becomes becomes the pawn of destiny so
and here goes fundy that's a very strong
idea and if d5 you should go all in on
the queen side idea
this is very typical where night innings
get lost despite the person up a pawn
oh he's going for it because if 96 is
played it feels good
but it's exactly how you lose night
endings because they're so bad at
stopping past pawns
oh beautiful move now he has knight d3
to protect the pawn on b2 bundy five
head fundy five head
oh he blundered okay bring the king in
croakie get your four key mode out dan
i'm on top of it dan thanks for giving
yourself fundy played incredible you're
the best danny and fundy also was
playing this so well even though he was
in a worse end game um but croaky's
gotta gotta try to bring his king in 96.
he needs to do whatever he can to get
the chances here but dude if croakies
finds knight d3 he did
he's gonna win the pawn
now croakies is right back at it
what a game by these guys
and yeah so white's just
up a pond now
[Music]
wow
uh oh this is not headed
bundy's way
yeah now croaky's just up a pawn and he
has the passer
oh and music that would be really scary
for you danny
like that's mandatory
for those who don't know the bet
say there's an outfit i'd rather not get
to go around like this made
chat made of pokey wins
um i don't even know what a cat mate is
but it sounds
hilarious get some obscure made with cat
ears i think
sorry
okay
um
all right you even got yourself on that
pun
well i just i looked at you and i
pictured it and i i couldn't hold it in
the left you can win on time just just
keep going that's actually a bad check
okay
five he's gonna win the party
he can't put me in check we go
oh wait okay you could just go a long
way around
uh oh this is scary for fundy
okay we have to go down yeah yeah very
scary we have to here just keep moving
quality chests chess
now fundy can just try to keep the
knight on on d7
or attack it i guess i like that as well
don't go here all right let's see what
history don't go near the pawn he can he
can only push this and take it so i
think we win
regardless of what happens and then we
have connected puns and he doesn't
then we can start pushing this wow
just don't make it a draw don't make it
a draw here's no time
we gotta find the best moves he has no
time
if we can make this not a draw then
we're so set
wait why is he saying not a draw fundy
should be happy with the draw did i miss
hear that
wants to
win i've respected r-e-s-p-e-c-t
well he does have opposition actually he
is winning now
or is he winning no i think it's it's
still a draw but it's very tricky
i think i blew it man
i think uh no no it's still a draw
ellen isn't this good for me though
all his moves are bad right
27 seconds for croakie
i think it's gonna be a draw they're too
good to yeah i think so too
which feels like a fair result here
great
oh my god he's only got
he's getting down on time
yep
i don't have enough time to find
something better there
[__] me that i feel like i should have
won this
it's okay at least he didn't lose it
but yeah croaky definitely was the one
to win until fundy i actually know they
both are chances they both had chances
this feels very fair
they both played so well i think it's
just gonna take it
i don't know man i don't know if i saw a
winner or a draw i don't know if that's
a winner i draw that
if i had like five more seconds
jesus
they could drink from that not overly
large overly large
liquid
holding vessel
i you can't just call it a bottle when
it's that big it's something else a
liquid vessel i like that
like i said it say
it's a cold liquid harboring vessel
did it tm all right we'll take it we'll
take it
oh my gosh hey this felt like a fair
result they both played well
bundy down a pawn in the opening but had
a lot of initiative
they both had winning chances ended up
in a draw we are going to see them
battle it out opposite colors for
the paw champs championship bracket
title
and you don't have a chance to win which
is a game
so no matter what would have happened
even the flag flagging is basically when
okay so flagging is when you run out of
time and he had six seconds left and i
have three minutes that's why
uh that's flagging
[Music]
i don't know why it's called that but
that's not
see we played
i'm curious
so white was continuously winning but
only slightly
the highest they've been up was like
plus two plus 2.3
so i think we played very well they
never heavily won and we never blundered
no
and they played an opening that i that i
don't know how to play so that's
actually quite good
to go to home accuracy 88
yeah i'm happy with that
all right
chat now
comes the fun
we're playing as white
if i can win
with the vienna
i will i will be so happy because i
started piano like crazy i i put like
five hours into it
i put like five hours into the vienna
uh would you like specific opening
um i think i still know it i didn't
refresh my memory so i could make i
could go wrong the vienna is along the
lines of this
so you have two different i'm just gonna
play it so i know myself so vienna is
like this they can either do that or
they can do this ideally you wanted to
do this because then you have um the
vienna gambit if they take it
um
if they take it it's really bad because
you can do this
they can't go to any of these squares
because they're all protected
as you can see
so they have to go back we put this here
to prevent the
the queen from attacking us
and
then
they do something like they do something
like that we did this they do this we do
that
they can't take because it's like
there's a there's a bunch of vertical
lines
now
if they do this
[Music]
we do this and we hope for that
if they do this we have
this
attacking this
they can do that
um and then funnily enough we have this
which is [__] beautiful so here's
what happens
our knight here
attacks the queen attacks this pawn
which would be check
we're also attacking this which would
take the rook and we're also attacking
that which will take the roof we are
attacking everything like this
um even if they take with check and we
can't take it it's not that bad we just
go here and we're fine they can't do
anything nothing nothing works
nothing nothing works
as long as you don't move this
um so in this position
you can either take this you can take
that there's a bunch of really cool
moves you can do
[Music]
i'm here just to elevate hey your mental
health is essential i'mma tell em
straight yeah hey yo don't talk about it
often but we gotta kill the stigma cause
we all deal with problems yeah so this
should be something normal to converse
about cause everybody has mental health
and we hurt no doubt yeah anxiety
depression got to overcome i be on my
job and i'm about to get it done i be
letting more lyrics drip up off the
tongue it's every night i'm shining like
the sun i'll be rhyming in the sash
yeah times in my life i've been
depressed yeah at times i felt just like
a mess
yeah but yo these types of organizations
will get you through the stress come on
rise above it we rise above it we in the
session for our cause and they love it
rising above it rising above it it's
everybody yo i can rhyme on any subject
i wonder if harry mack does birthdays
my rejection if you could just rent him
out for your birthday danny that would
be awesome i could use that guy for a
for a birthday party or two any hooters
we are we
are yeah
i was gonna i was gonna give you a
little rap
from you
yeah yeah but now i i forgot it so let's
just go back to rise above the disorder
it seems like a higher priority
like harry said we've all been depressed
rise above the rest let's do it guys hey
we're almost there everybody we are
almost there get me to at least 33 000
and we've raised 100k with chess.com
2xing the community's donations
let's go let's get there
and uh and and give all that we can in
these last moments because guess what
it's all on the line right now here we
go
oh my gosh i
so much so much could happen here i i
what did we just learn i think croakies
was the slightly better player start to
finish but in the fastest moments fundy
got the nod by the way alexander real
quick
this is the closest this is the closest
match we've had with channel points of
any pogchamps match it ended 52 for
croakie 48 for fundy
wow
this is so close
i know who you're cheering for
um
not biased at all just you have
something embarrassing on the line got a
sicilian going on they're close in terms
of rating um
could be anyone's game this is this is
super fun i feel whoa did somebody just
donate ten thousand dollars oh it's
eternal that means we've sold out we
said it yesterday that's it we're okay i
for i forgot they were donating
everything to charity for a minute we
are well over our goal right now but
that doesn't mean we should stop that
means we're at 120 000 raise total with
that massive donation eternal thank you
so much
for donating everything to rad and that
makes me feel good makes everyone feel
good
yay
okay we've got 41 400 danny's being dad
jokey that was my rhyme
now i felt like i was ready to say it
because we we got the donation wait will
you say it again
um we're here watching croakie danny's
being dad jokey
that's it those two lines you know what
harry mack is mortality is really
talented it's hard to put these together
oh man the hairy man's got nothing on
you alexandra got nothing all right
we're in a sicilian yeah
in a sicilian with a closed sicilian
structure but no pawn on f4 so it's
actually small edge croakies
but
but probably the best idea against this
bishop c4 is to get aggressive here and
even to play e6 which is not what
croakies wants we know he loves the
fianchetto
so um it'd be really cool if fundy
prepared this against him knowing that
his inclination is to play the g6 type
variations yep
i uh i don't know i i
oh
yeah look at croakies e5 my my
b5 my mind look at you you're in rhyme
count mode
but b5 in my mind don't run oh my god
what is wrong with me
it's close enough
i still like e6 here
yeah e6 is best
you're preparing to bring the knight up
thank you to every donation we're
getting awesome guys thank you so much
guys and gals
1383 i don't know what that means but
the year it was a year maybe it was the
year scotland was free
1383.
he is so quiet
usually i feel like he's talking more
but he knows how high the stakes are
right now yeah
he is
i'm gonna do this first
i could have pushed this pawn he takes i
take with knight he takes i think with
queen
[Music]
i can still push the spine
they go here and i accomplish this one
i have to make an escape square for my
bishop
pushed upon he goes here and he traps on
bishop wow
really really bad
he is seeing it and he's not going to
step into any blunders here i like it he
could push a3 if he wants just to be
safe make some space for him
we'd literally just take he takes i go
here with knight
[Music]
i'll take this knight
and they're both kind of thinking the
same thing until kroki played bishop g4
which
designed to go after that knight and
open up d4
these two guys are not chess players by
trade they're not even chess streamers
by trade if you're tuning in from twitch
front page for the first time go give
both fundy and croakies a follow because
they have earned it with their their
progress here in this
event that is pogchamps 4 brought to you
by coinbase it's been amazing this is
this is some really great chess
and i don't want it to end i'm sad
yeah and it's also really inspirational
for anybody who's been you know maybe a
little nervous to pick up chess they've
been playing chess for about a year now
they're already playing at an incredibly
an incredibly
nice level i don't know what the right
way to say it is
um nice
nice is nice nice and easy it is easy to
say
and i think what matters the most is
when you find a friend of yours who has
a similar rating and you can play
against them it's competitive it's fun
you feel like you're progressing they're
playing opening theory here they haven't
been making blunders i know chad i said
nice
uh nice level thanks chad just just keep
the spam up
nice level
yeah okay 95 that's that's an
interesting idea though
okay
holy bejeezer snaps wait a second is
there something nutty here
where you take e5 move the knight and
check mate on f7
i know what you're thinking
motez gambit for the win hold on i don't
think i'm wrong oh yeah i can take here
because if you take here it's mate and
if you take it yeah but what if you take
with the other pawn i fork town in the
end get your fork emotes out everybody
boom
and this is actually
what's the peace count at the end there
i think in the end white has won a pawn
so all that for nothing i guess just a
pawn but still freaking sexy that's
freaking off yeah no it is that that's a
really nice tactic it would be so cool
to see that come into play here okay
look fundy took first
oh and then he can take with the knight
on e5 wait did he have to do that
are you sure he played that and you
didn't just move it and i think he did
he played
we can also do this
he takes i take
no it's just not that good
i like this more
oh no no no
ah
it's just when there's such a beautiful
it's not his fault it's hard to see but
i just i i needed i needed that
we both needed it
oh it's hard it's hard danny
you know what people say it's so easy
being a commentator you just go blah
blah put in some dad jokes some puns but
it's the emotional turmoil i think it's
only botez gambits and dad jokes around
here all right we also are seeing
commentary comment we're seeing
we're seeing variations knight takes e5
and bishop takes f7
checkmate
wow that would have been so beautiful
okay but okay
we've got a game and now his his bishop
isn't actually trapped because he can
grab the pawn and then he has that a4
square that is going to be liberated
after the pawn on b5 captures
and it actually gets really really spicy
for black because this is a very
very irritating pin so
as long as fundy doesn't fail to see the
obvious which he's already captured i
think he's in great shape and again i
have to observe the same as game one
brokey's croakies uh kryptonite is the
clock
yep and the funny thing is both of them
have a very weird king position
not a lot of safety on either side
very awkward awkward af as the kids say
all right looks like he's about to take
on c4 i like him trade taking with the
knight first to force the bishop trade
yeah it's still a little better for
funding but i agree
but i should have taken with the i
should have taken with the e pawn man oh
for more reasons
[Music]
reminding me that i didn't need that
extra cup of coffee at the break
yeah oh man i am getting all jacked
these pawn structures are so [__]
what's going on
[Music]
okay so what is he gonna do with his
king here
what a move
if fundy played that not just to get the
palm but also castle long then
i might not be wearing a cat mate suit
at the end of this i'll tell you that
because fundy is on a roll right now
he is it also allows you to play here
though
this is unprotected he's going to push
it down one or something like that
wait why is he pointing towards a7
should we go here okay he pushes it down
one we go here with our with our bishop
we win the broker or we win the pawn
right oh wow that is an aggressive thing
i would rather you castle long
yeah but at least this queen isn't
getting trapped he doesn't have that
much to worry about yeah that's fair
okay
position
don't forget to trademark that danny
it's not a wonderful life
jesus dude is fire says okay dk he he
has been playing incredibly
you go here
no i like this actually i like this
i want to attack i want to i want to be
a dick
so if we go here
he protects it like that
that's the way you do it if you do if
you if he pushes it we go like this
queen under pressure queen goes here i
take he take i take pawn dude um if he
does this we have this attacking the
rook and attacking the pawn uh rook can
go here
let me go back here attacking that
i don't think we'll be inviting to the
next pog champs he's going oh no
he's going to be he's just too good he's
going to be look at he just calculated
it
brilliantly that is a that is what a
master whatever the ambassador would do
in this position he just did it that's
exactly what we wanted
and he did it quickly because now he
does he just played incredibly
he's gonna have to move his move his he
had he has to move his queen to one of
these spots i take a screen he takes i
take a spawn
and we're just up and then we go back
here to the to defend that
and we're upon
dude
i think either way we're up upon
turning out to be a perfect day
okay so what is croakies best shot here
i don't know sorry i was busy spamming
chess calm fundy emotes in the chat
that's how impressed i am um
i like it you're a chatter
wow that
that was actually a really good move
that was probably yeah it's a very spicy
move
it looks like it may be bad
you're gonna get away with holding onto
the pond
he's trading this is totally fine now
yep croaky's just holding on it's a
spicy meatball this is spicy i'll meet
the ball yeah
why do we what are you doing with this
mario
i don't know i just you started it i'm
continuing it it was one of my
favorite accents so far um
okay bishop d4 he's protecting looks
good and now the awkward king positions
are no longer a problem
what's funny is we've been applauding
fundy being up on the clock i actually
think that moment right there
would prove critical
let's actually show it on the analysis
board real quick fundy played very
quickly there but actually
taking a5 was a much better exchange for
white giving up the b pawn which felt
counterintuitive but it's because the a
pawn is just nasty here you move the
bishop and start pushing
and
the game could be over very quickly so
he he very quickly played what looked
better it feels better to bring the
bishop here but actually bishop takes a5
i think was his best chance to win
yeah i i totally agree with you there
um
and now it's getting a little bit tricky
honestly a move like kingy 2 might be
one of his best moves here just connect
the rook start getting the king ready
for the end game yep and
use the fact that croakies is down on
the clock here
agreed oh i didn't love king f8 maybe i
i like pushing the e pawn and getting
the king to e7 for him
ah this is not this is where fundy is
needs to slow down so he he's got he's
gotten an edge on the clock but now he
needs to use it as a weapon and think in
the critical moment
alright so
a good move bishop c3 if he plays it
this bishop is very very powerful
i like that i want his rook to maybe
rook me five don't go to the contrary
[__]
yeah
the long line
no needs to do what you called for a
while ago get the king to e2
this three on two is not doing anything
you want it you want to use your
majority to create a past pawn but it
takes time
most new players don't really focus on
end games
these two pawns are pretty strong
wait e6 hangs f6 he doesn't see it
f6 is hanging
for the bishop yeah
he didn't take it
he's going to have to take it i will
depending on what happens in this
post-match commentary i think that would
be that the coaching in me is going to
coach him he's going to take over i got
to give fundy
lock weapon management advice because
he's doing such a good job when it
matters be up on the clock but you've
got to train yourself to convert
and think when you need it okay we have
a pawn that can that can vibe yes good
stuff he does not he has these five we
have these four versus one solo if we
can make this solo guy go
all the way up
that's a win
but we have to go past it
if i push this one
push up here
this isn't looking great for croakie
this is also a problem too
that holy [__] is pawn push might have
lost me to the game even even though
they don't even thicker
kind of a yikes
by the way
oh
all right so he's gonna have to get the
black king or a bishop over to the other
side of the board if he has any chances
at stopping the pawn from promoting to
b8 maybe something like bishop f5 and
then pushing d5 to control b8
um
because
well i guess the king would still catch
up
i was going to say that
bundy has to be really careful because
if he pushes this pawn and and loses it
the king is close enough as long as
croakies plays king of fate it's within
the box look at this everybody we call
this the box
i'll draw it they're moving too fast
as long as your king is within the box
you can catch the pawn
and now okay funny's doing the right
thing you need the king to help you
can't just push to a win
here comes fundy's end game technique
let's see
much better
keep the king off the color square of
the bishop we gotta go back here
he can't go here that's the advantage
let me go back here
go here first
[Music]
okay you gotta play king c4 now though
and come back to the other side not you
don't want to go king a5 if he backs up
[Music]
coming back king c4 d5 was the was a
clear path how do we win
alexandra this is
man high level mistakes being made i say
that with a compliment it's high level
mistakes this feels good but it's wrong
you have to use the fact that you've got
the king stuck
to switch and do principle of two
weaknesses
which is go to this side of the board
and start targeting everything else
he could lose this game now with the
king on a5
yeah he has to be very careful that he
doesn't accidentally end up
losing b5 um the thing is black is not
going to make progress on the king's
side so it's still hard for fundy to
lose this now
yeah uh
we'll see if are they going to offer a
bishop trade and that's going to change
everything
oh i i yeah that would scare me or even
a move like bishop e5 and d4 could be a
little scary but then of course the pawn
on d4 might end up being a weakness
itself
wow i haven't this could be anyone's
game a reminder on the clock though
croakies a minute funny six minutes
that's a big deal
music is a big deal
okay that's good he might get his king
to c5
quick response from fundy
double view
that's not too good either
i can do that and then this maybe
oh man
nervous let's go here
yeah
this is
this is just
wait did i just win the pawn hold on if
he goes here i go here
he takes i take he goes here i go here
uh
oh
that looks there's more on the right
side it's actually a draw if all if the
best moves are played if they're traded
oh wait yeah because the king the king
can end up uh
yeah but there's so many mysteries
opportunities for both players here
yep and i'm more on the right side right
i love that this is being decided in the
end game
but i think if anyone can win now i
think it might be croakies with the more
active king
yes
although fundy's king might end up on h4
oh he offered a draw i don't i don't
even know if it's a draw to accept it or
not i think they're both so nervous they
just want the next game oh my god i
think that's what happened
okay we have another tiebreaker
all right
they [__] debated me with the draw
for and i wasted like 10 seconds of my
clock so then i got like priced in to
accept it
ridiculous
i was i i wasted like 25 of my remaining
clock
thinking about if i'm supposed to
take the draw if it's a drawn position
if i'm even allowed to take a draw
croaky seems like the kind of guy who
would start questioning the meaning of
life after a draw for you know he just
gets so deep into it starts spiraling
hey
we said these are the top players we're
gonna see some grand master draws i love
that for both of the final matches it's
going into the tiebreaker which means
it's going to be three plus two with the
better performing player getting the
white side of the pieces
and he's not wrong i mean fundy did kind
of debate him i guess right at the right
moment made him think about it so he had
no choice because i think fundy saw the
more active king and even though it
objectively was a draw i think he was
also nervous like oh man i might lose
this i'm going to offer a draw now
and
this is some of the highest level pog
champs we've ever had i mean i know
we've had a lot of a lot of great
players but this chess is really amazing
so this is not a draw because
totally because of missed opportunities
this is a draw because both players are
playing well
and here we go it's time for blitz uh
don't go anywhere everybody the pog
champs for title is on the line we will
be back in just a few minutes after this
short break
do you think i'm gonna
do not understand
it's not okay
it's very much not okay it's to the
point where i can be respectful even
though it's about 20k okay
just i'm saying that
that's a million i'm gonna be real
ninety percent of the streamers you're
watching are millionaires
ninety percent
i'm gonna say that
[Music]
so you are well i don't really stream
often do i
see i'm i'm see you can exclude me i'm
not the person that streams twice twice
a day okay
but the people that stream a lot
you can assume they are
analyze the game
92 accuracy i was winning heavily until
the end
[Music]
i don't see how to win
so this is this is a win of me
so previously was a win of his now to
win of me we are literally
i'm not even kidding we are equal match
this is like an eagle fight
but the advantage is
i play a lot of blitz
a lot of blitz
so if there's if there's three minutes
on the clock
i feel like i can win so does he does he
oh [__]
it was a missed win
[Music]
why
why is that bad
because you're up a pawn
that's a missed win because you won a
pawn after five moves i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna say that's a that's not a
missed win in my book that is [__]
that is not a missed win that is not
like oh you lost because it no shut up
shut up
don't be nice win
i could have won this i could have
jane looks like i could have you see
okay so let's let's see right so he
would have gone here
i go here
oh wait that's that's kind of bad he
goes here
no like what can you do you will just
dance around this like he goes he goes
here you lost
you will literally just dance it'll
literally be a dance
actually
oh my god i could have won
wait
so this would have happened right
he moves here
i move on he has to move
he goes back here oh no it doesn't work
[Music]
if you thought we were kidding
i will legit give my likeness to any
energy company
that wants that
liquid elo whoa whoa danny where's my 10
cup for coming up with the name what's
going on here scamaz if anybody picks it
up you get 10
so right on and now i've said it on
camera i can't take it back sponsors
sponsors please pick it up please pick
it up
let's go liquid elo makes you better at
chess
boy do i need some of that
uh all right i like it i like it this is
it for all the marbles quite literally
twenty thousand dollars to the winner of
this chess game that is starting right
now odd champs for coinbase hype by the
way alexandra
uh
and 90
for fundy 89 and 85. these two guys are
playing chess
they are playing some high
accuracy
this is what we like to see
let's see if they're going to make
improvements on their last game
but my music has just stopped
pretty tilted about this no notice he
turned off the music not a great time
oh i thought that might help him focus
but he probably needs it
okay
did fundy look at the game report
see that he was winning on 95.
this is why you use game report on
chess.com
that is true
if he pulls it off it will be deserved
because he did his homework
[Music]
liquid eagle will come in all sizes chad
gallon size
get order a pint i'll take a pint of
liquid elon
look at
this please tell me you used game report
right
he takes it with this one no no he took
it with this one oh now does it change
okay i push this
still winning there
instead of h3
[Music]
what is this i take
he takes i go here
and then queen here
queen here
oh but now we know the missed win
actually we know the missed win now
it'd be hilarious if that's gonna be
actually like how i went
okay now there's variety
push this
go
back i think i pushed that right
great move
nice move on the clock
bundy listening to the same music that
sea dog listens to during tournament r2
that's probably a bad sign given how
that ended for sea dog
jojo siwa
animation
now it's turning into the headspace
now it's actually different
i can go here to attack this but he'll
castle
[Music]
for the other grind
sorry guys i got the name wrong i see
you in chat
[Music]
if you put me in check
who wishes to like push this i can do
this too
[Music]
like i remember you
will fundy see that he can run the
h-pawn to attack g6
yeah now that e5 square
fundy sees it
[Music]
nice active move
they're playing so well
moving his king off of
the pin
oh funny got nervous he should have just
taken
now croakies can
defend yeah you got it rook g8
[Music]
yeah he was probably afraid of knight f3
ideas
f4 looks pretty spicy for croakie
some point
yeah
yeah f4 would really make it harder to
defend and fund it looks like he's going
to find it not pushed upon though
i push this bonus back because i don't
think i have an attacker
put my rope here and then another okay
so i take this with my rook
or my my my queen
put these up on the clock my queen
we we don't want to attack this we don't
want to do that
we want to put this guy this guy here
he goes here
we take
he takes
okay f6 would be just witty here
not even looking for it i want to make
an escape square for my bishop first oh
no
[Music]
feel that cat made out you can take
tightening around my neck like a noose
[Music]
that's a good move oh crow piece is
getting 30 seconds versus a minute
[Music]
oh you see bishop g5
oh my god
very well spotted
oh no damn cat mate
oh my god
very well spotted
it's very very good
that is a great move he should take and
then take the night at least have some
kind of compensation
is
[Music]
oh my god okay he needs to flock with
the bishop he needs to give it a shot
don't pre-move
he needs bishop e1 uh e3 sorry nice
no
[Music]
oh my god nine seconds no to the father
i thought i was up
no no no
three pawn on b7
[Music]
oh
yeah dude
holy [__]
yes
oh my god
let's [__] go
[Music]
oh my god
look at this
we were [__]
winning
and then i i didn't see i didn't see
dang it
wow
that
was
anybody's match the closest pog champs
final i have seen so far
incredible comeback from fundy who did
not lose his cool after dropping the
queen for two pieces croakies was doing
so well
ended up flagging oh must be painful
heartbreaking for croakies you could you
could feel it through the silence there
was no music there was hardly a response
and fundy
is your pog champs
or champion
congratulations fundy incredibly played
huge progress
you know even if this is how the last
game ended he deserves a win
i think we gotta bring up our eternal
play of the game i don't even quite know
what to choose i'm with all the rest of
the fans and that
um
you know this
could have gone anyone's way but i'm
gonna go back to the queen the queen
lost right there i think like you said
obviously croaky's found it but the fact
that fundy didn't lose his cool you
heard him he acknowledged it great find
great find and then he played fast i
mean i don't even know what to say what
a wild moment that was i appreciate how
quickly fundy just focused in and
relocated everything he could to keep
this thing alive and eventually was
rewarded for it on the clock
yep
that is what he had to do
and you know when it's the final match
sometimes you lose a piece and you end
up just
giving up a little bit and he did the
complete opposite he found the best
continuation how to win two pieces for
the queen he was defending very well he
played quickly
i guess this is going to be the eternal
moment of the game danny
if you agree type eternal you can also
type eternal throughout many of you
already knew that because you linked up
your account long ago huge shout out to
our partners and and sponsors eternal
for everything they brought to our
charity at rad for the the the packs
they've been giving away to three lucky
winners every day and if you are one of
the many more than or thousands i don't
know how many but it was thousands of
people that
that bought eternal uh eternal pog
champs four collectible packs all of it
went to the charity and thank you so
much for everything that they did and uh
your last chance to type eternal
just signed about let's let's just look
at how it finished here the championship
is officially in the books fundy takes
it in tiebreak fashion a heartbreaker
for the magic the gathering star
brokies and huge donation right there
another thousand dollars coming in
thank you so much amazing trick thank
you that is so generous
oh you guys are so appreciated north of
125 000 total rage with the matching
donors from chess.com so awesome it's
not over yet if you want to throw in
now's the time we are going to take a
break and when we come back the final
interviews of pogchamps 4 presented by
coinbase
[Music]
i think i speak for everyone when i say
i can't wait for andrea botes to eat a
crapload of kimchi right fundy yes i i
would do it for you i said i said it and
i did it you're not gonna wear that mate
suit you're not gonna do it
it was heartbreaking either way at one
point at one point stephen i felt the
cat made tightening around my body in a
very straight jacket done away i thought
you had it you were close
and in in those moments i mean i we
don't want to do anything talk
negatively but just you guys you guys
were amazing
so much drama stephen thank you for
everything you brought to chess
everything you brought to the event over
the last few weeks you were an absolute
joy to watch you were a rock star
you're inspiring to see what you did so
i just i hope that i know it stings
right now man but i hope you walk away
feeling good about everything you
accomplished
i think it was an amazing experience
like the whole process like not only
just playing the games but like learning
chess as a whole and kind of going
through that that process with chess but
if in the final they're fun there's just
a little bit too strong like they're
fighting over you're telling me you just
started learning jess
and not too long ago now
and you're this good
i play a lot i mean i play like i've
been playing four to eight hours a day
the whole time so
damn i saw a lot of practice and almost
enough
and fundy you have also improved so
quickly i mean i remember watching you
from when we first did the minecraft
chess tournament and seeing your
progression to here is insane not to
mention your 2400 tactic rating which is
still mine
but i need you to get to 2500 that's
your next goal yeah i don't know if chad
knows but basically um i i do a lot of
puzzles and my rating on puzzles is much
higher than my actual rating it's
actually 2 400. and when i looked at
like the friends list i had a higher
rating than alexandra and i was like
what
it wasn't updated it wasn't updated as
soon as you sent me that you triggered
me i went i got it to 2500. i'm gonna
let you catch up and when you catch up
then i'm gonna gain another hundred elos
just make sure you keep training now
that you're a pog champion yeah i am i
am heavily struggling but i will get to
2 500. it it'll happen it'll 100 happen
i saw that puzzle written and i was very
very scared of it
but in the end you played incredibly
sorry go ahead danny no i was gonna say
in the in the end it was your it was
your mouth skills so take us into your
your confidence there because you know
when when steven found bishop g5 and
wonder queen your attitude alexander and
i were listening into you so we heard
every word you were like oh my god great
find great find by him but then you
buckled down and you just started
blitzing it out what has gone into your
practice over the last few weeks that
had you keep your cool in the time
scramble
um well it's mainly because i don't have
the attitude of i need to win or
anything like that so if i am heavily
losing as opposed to going oh no i
blundered i more go like wow that's a
good fine i more like appreciate the
other person for seeing a really good
move and even if i would have lost that
i would have still been like wow that's
really cool
um and that like whenever i'm losing it
it doesn't go into my head like oh god
i'm losing it's more of like the other
person is playing good i also got to
play good and like no matter what
happens i'll just i'll just try and keep
that cool and i mean
whether i got lucky or not i i don't
actually know um steven definitely was
winning in the end like he got my queen
um
i was a few moves away from checkmate
and i i don't know it was one of the
most closest match the closest matches
um that i've ever played genuinely
it's a pretty sense there's drastic
stuff to stay present um
stephen
go ahead go ahead funny what are you
gonna say
no no no no i i tried to
you're my cutout and i tried to empty
the silence by saying just yeah
um
even i we know we know how bad you
wanted this we know that you worked hard
you you you know you both deserved it
and i hope i hope this isn't the last
that the chess world gets to gets to see
of you because this was amazing we've
got we've got other events that go on
like winter stays fundies played in one
of those so we you know we got other
ways to get you involved um but
i just want to say what a joy it was to
watch someone make you you know no jokes
you guys were playing accuracy was
through the roof 90 we're checking every
game and i i don't think i've ever seen
someone make this much progress so fast
even so again
thank you so much and i and i hope uh
hope you're feeling as best you can i
just want to give you a big yeah you're
big
genuinely a really strong player
i mean i love to win but i don't mind
losing to a better player and fun day
was definitely a better i mean i was
i i couldn't believe that i got the
first two games of the draw i did i knew
there but i was very happy with the
first two draws so that should tell you
that i i knew that he was like
tactically superior to me so
i would i was settling for the drugs
like
he offered me a drawing game too and i
didn't i didn't even know if it was like
a one end game for me or for him or if
it was a draw i just took it
yeah
yeah that end game was a draw actually
it was a little bit tricky for both
sides and i'm sure you're both feeling
the pressure so taking the draw there
made so much sense to just get it on and
go to the next game yeah
yeah people in my chat were also saying
like oh you had six minutes you could
have flagged them but no i i i think in
that situation like we had like what
four pawns each they were perfectly
stacked on top of each other there was
not much to do i i think it was just
generally a draw
plus with the increment it always makes
the board um have the final say which is
by design right so i think i think you
were right that it was a draw and better
not to not to try and flaggle
anyway we could talk forever guys we we
really enjoyed this show it was just
awesome and everything was happening as
the kids would say the chat was lit i
tried not to make it as awkward as af as
i normally do oh by the way fundy
yeah i hope you like belts
i do like belts
i held it upside down but thank you to
grip6 our sponsors for the belts and uh
this should look good on you gold looks
good on you
yeah no it does it does wait wait wait
wait wait
it does oh my god oh
my god he's wrong he does look good on
me he's gonna be matching and just fully
dripped out in gold
[Music]
we expect picks when the belt arrives
man and seriously congratulations for
winning
winning pog champs for and uh you know i
can't wait for the next next chess event
because you know fundy fundy apparently
is uh is not going anywhere
and
oh my god
we just got a twenty thousand dollar
donation nineteen thousand five hundred
dollars from someone
wow
from hotshot gg
20 grand jesus christ
i'm taking my glasses off for that one
that is the single largest donation
we've ever had
that is on free who is hotshot gg that's
amazing
one of the co-founders of clg if it's
actually him
oh my god him
yeah just that is we need to confirm
whether it is or not but i just want to
point out i'm also alive you know i also
uh donation
we
we threw some we threw some subs you
guys away but not 19 500 work that is
amazing thank you so much we have now
raised more than we did for pogchamps
three this is the most wow just.com has
ever raised for a single event it's
coming for charity that's hype
thank you thank you guys uh thank you
everyone for making this amazing steven
and fundy you guys thank you so much for
everything you brought and
congratulations again to both you on
amazing tournaments
had a blast guys fantastic event that
was amazing thank you
thank you guys
oh my gosh alexandra nineteen thousand
five hundred dollars that's that's you
said it's one of the co-founders of clg
oh a fountain he he founded clg and he's
also a league of legends player um
really a legend in so many different
ways and with that donation just so
generous so kind we really appreciate it
i i don't know if it's actually him it
probably is though um so thank you
wow
that is nuts
i did not think we were going gonna
surpass pogchamps three i just i was
ready to say how amazing it was how
close we got
that
that this event you know
um
was was incredible and a little bit
different time for for chess right now
than it was in february to be honest
given the the height of the queen's
gambit and stuff like that but we just
we just blew past that and i'm i'm
speechless
that is
awesome um and chess.com is going to be
matching this donation right yep we are
matching
every dollar times two
to the charity wow
wow i love that so much
um we hope that
we hope that they just i mean obviously
they will continue the things they're
doing we hope that anyone and everyone
takes advantage of of the help they they
they might need and uh and rad is there
waiting with uh
with now a little bit more support than
they had before
and let's
i don't even know what else to say
oh my god i saw a funny comment in chat
the donation should be the eternal play
of the stream
donate you type eternal right now chad
you actually can do that type eternal
yeah exactly and get it nominated the
the collectible pack is not actually
done yet that's what they do um and all
you have to do is type eternal right now
to nominate it and it'll it'll get added
so
um
there you go
what are we doing now we're reminding
everybody of what the day was mr beast
beat rubius and tie breaks it was epic
it had
it had you know
content throws and accidental throws we
learned about stalemate we all got
closer we had behind the scenes phone
calls with jimmy who by the way has been
texting me he says now now it's time to
win the whole thing now that he's won
the consolation bracket i say okay that
means you have to wait you have to not
wait six months before your next chess
lesson buddy and he promises he's gonna
grind um
speaking of grinding alexandra fundy and
steven
i'm glad i'm not wearing a cat made
outfit but i am heartbroken for the
magic man
yeah i know it was it was really tough
to see that flag um
but he
wait yes oh no i i said i told the
community if they got to 50 000 i would
wear the cat made outfit anyway oh crap
oh did you really
yeah well danny that's amazing we get to
see you i i think in theory cat made
outfit i think in theory we reached all
of our goals
honestly um yeah let's take a look at
the goals baby just remind everyone what
how they get to be rewarded
okay andreas andrea's gotta do cutie
cinderella cosplay she has the wig
already actually okay i'm gonna do a
bullet wings challenge and then the
grand prize is eric and i
are gonna do a hot tub stream i know
everyone's excited to see that um
and it's gonna happen so
two men one tub what could go wrong one
tub and scene whatever happens happens
and things okay we're gonna do it this
is incredible and thank you again so
much to
um
the massive donation we just had for
1905 and everybody who brought it it's
been amazing and apparently
i told andrea she has to send me the cat
made outfit or i'm not going to do it so
she's got to ship it to me um
alexander we had some people win
yesterday
uh
we did
four matches three winners per match
congratulations to everybody who won and
uh you know the entire community won
because all of the collectibles on
eternal gg the funds are not just going
to go towards a really cool
collectible game online but also towards
the charity so this is awesome and for
those who win today we will tweet uh we
will tweet later today or first thing
tomorrow once the random drawing is done
um so just follow the at chesscom
twitter account if you're not already
doing that shame on you but all you got
to do is follow it we will tweet the
winners an image very similar to that
will come out tomorrow uh there's still
one more chance before tomorrow to play
in the coin based community cup it's
been happening daily after pogchamps
just something something for the fans
for the kids at home
have a look you know not just kids
full grown adults as well also can play
in the coinbase community cup
and uh
and dinosaurs can play and aliens can
play it's not a biased community anyone
can play any anything
yeah we get a denny you guys if you're
watching you can play
um i know that watching chess makes
people want to play chess as well and
the cool thing is that in these arenas
you usually get paired with people who
have a similar level to you so it's not
as intimidating and it's kind of cool to
just play alongside other people who
have been watching the same event as you
wow we just got another hundred dollars
the uh the goal and another hundred
dollars coming in
air
air hadoken
john k
um
this is amazing stuff and um
thank you so much to the support
if any other donations come in we are
wrapping up now so probably the alert
won't be live because the show must end
at some point but alexander we did it
another pogchamps in the books
wow
four pog champs
we've had four pog champs and the first
one was
about a year and a half ago right yep
it's it's been an incredible journey
this is just so
different than what you're used to for
chess events um these personalities make
everything super interesting and i'm
just so grateful that we have cool
events like this that are accessible for
people regardless of their chest level
and before we before we leave make sure
you tell your sister what's coming
uh oh god
danny's spicy kimchi uh andrea made for
andre andrea actually really struggle
struggles with spicy food i'm gonna
enjoy her having to eat this it's not
i'm not even gonna send her the really
spicy kind but it's very good for you
it's for it's fermented cabbage that's
what kimchi is it's full of probiotics
and it's it's honestly a superfood so
i'm about to change andrea's life
somehow i have to wear a cat made outfit
and and maybe change my marriage forever
and she gets to change her life in a
healthy direction with some kimchi so i
don't know who won here somehow hey it
might spice up the marriage danny you
never know everybody could do it i'll
ask my wife if she's in maybe she'll see
me in the cat main outfit and things
could i don't know we'll just this is
about to get really awkward
oh well this was a pleasure danny it was
great commentating with you everybody
watching thank you so much and to all of
the players who came out here tried
their best played chess in front of tens
of thousands of people and we just saw a
lot of progress and it's always super
inspiring to see this event well said
thank you to the whole crew to my team
to everyone working super hard there's
been more put into this event than we've
ever had and uh and it was awesome
everything everything that uh that
happened so thank you again thank you to
the community our mods everybody working
hard not hardly working alexandra and
all of the co-hosts um that i got to
work with thank you so much
and i think that's it i think we're
going to sign off pogchamps 4 was
presented by coinbase and it was awesome
goodbye everybody
[Music]
so
you